Tone to it.
Okay.
Tone of experience.
You're going,
hi Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the fleshlight Joe Rogan
experience podcast.
Me,
that's me.
How dare I,
I still write by Joe Rogan experience podcast brought to you by the flashlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link for the flashlight and enter in
the code name Brogan,
you get 15% off.
Dave,
you ever used one house?
Yes,
I have.
Fucking powerful product,
beautiful products.
A real solid product you can get behind.
It's Thor's magical hammer.
Yeah.
Pleasure.
It's the best thing for men.
There's been no 10 greater.
It's way better than regular masturbation.
It's way better.
And if,
uh,
like I said my name and get yourself a discount,
don't be scared.
homey.com and if you,
I'm also a,
we're sponsored by on it.com the makers of Alpha brain,
Alpha brain,
a cognitive.
I'm going to give you some of these men.
They're,
they're interesting.
They're pills that are supposed to make you think better.
I love it.
Um,
and a lot of debate on these things.
And this is my,
my take on any of this.
If anybody has questions about whether or not they should buy something like
this,
please don't buy it.
This is what you should do.
Just research the word nootropic.
Look up nootropics,
look up whatever sketchy evidence there is on whether or not they work.
Look up,
you know,
buy a book on it for research the ingredients,
test them on yourself and if you want to try off a brain,
try it by buying the ingredients in bulk.
Buy them in bulk.
Don't even buy it from us by,
it's from whatever it is,
the exact amount of each ingredient are listed on the website,
on a dog,
Tom o,
n I t and just copy it,
copy it and steal the formula and don't give us any money.
I just hope you try it.
I it's,
it's uh,
to me it's a fascinating sort of,
uh,
an idea that you can enhance your health through supplements and you can enhance
your thinking through a mental supplement.
I mean,
I'm totally work for me and I quick.
Yeah,
it's nice.
I,
it was very interesting to see myself think clear like I saw,
like they,
it was weird.
It's doing something,
you know,
and they did use it,
some of the ingredients on Alzheimer's patients,
so they know that there's something going on with what the does and how it
interacts with the human mind.
But uh,
and the,
the,
the bottom line about it is there's a money back guarantee,
100% money back guarantee and we stand by that.
So,
uh,
if you go to Joe rogan.net and see the link for that and clicking the link and
put in my name and uh,
enter in the code name Rogan,
you get 10% off that too.
All right.
That's fucking commercials are over their gross to me,
to David.
Tell here bitches.
Thanks for having me on a ride.
Kids Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
Okay,
Ladies and gentlemen,
my pow Mr. David Towel.
I haven't,
I've known David Tell for many,
many a moon the frog.
I remember the first time I ever saw you on stage two is at catch a rising star
in New York.
That was a fuck.
It was like,
wow.
[inaudible] 91 or something like that place is long
gone.
Great little spot.
It was a great club.
You're right.
The only thing that was weird about that club was there was a god damn mirror
behind you.
So you looked at yourself when you were on stage.
You remember like your eye?
Yeah.
Cross a.
So while you on stage,
you,
you see yourself like a whole huge mirror was ridiculous.
Did you catch yourself?
Like acting,
posing,
and I taught,
I felt excited.
Get My,
my manager [inaudible] he called me on it.
He goes,
what are you looking at yourself in the mirror?
You could see yourself bombing your watch your own dream and float on a cloud.
That's gotta be a nightmare on stage.
Watch yourself bomb.
Yeah.
I only,
I only performed there a couple of times.
It was a great club.
Cool little spot.
Yeah.
I forget like that.
You did some time in New York?
Yeah.
Yeah,
when I first moved there.
But you know what?
I was so used to,
the way they did it in Boston,
I was so used to driving and doing road gigs that I would be like in town,
I couldn't make any money.
It was like they were like,
you know,
sent was like not much money.
Like what was it set at like a like or Carol likes to go weekday set or I guess
it wouldn't be Caroline.
See,
it'd be like the comic strip.
Well it used to be like a cab fare,
you know,
I remember like in the late eighties,
early nineties,
it was just like cab fare and a meal and then now it's probably like 25 bucks a
set.
And that was after like a big,
you know,
strike that we had.
And uh,
yeah,
for a while there there was no money and isn't that crazy?
Yeah.
Think about it then you're performing and that's the only reason they're open.
They're open because they're selling comedy performers don't get any money.
Is that like the audience comes in,
like,
especially on a,
it's not a headliner show,
it's just like,
you know,
a showcase show where it's just like tag teaming and they'll come in like
they're,
you know,
expecting to see like some kind of like,
uh,
whatever,
like a Cirque de Solei or something.
And it's like,
no,
we're just all coming up here trying or dick and pussy jokes,
you know,
trying to like build material and they get really disappointed and like we're,
we're making like,
you know,
less than you would if you,
were a fluffer on a fucking Mexican donkey show.
So,
yeah.
How did that happen?
How did it become such a,
a,
a club owner centric environment?
I don't know.
It's like earning your bones,
you know,
how it is.
Like,
you know,
like first of all,
like I'd say like my first 10 years,
it was debatable whether,
whether I deserve to be paid or not,
you know,
it was like,
so touch and go like,
hey,
easy.
But I agree.
I know that feeling.
But yeah,
and then like there's,
you know,
then once you finally like realize that like,
you know your power,
you know,
you know how to do it and then you're like,
I can't believe you know,
this is like slavery.
Just pure slavery.
Yeah.
Well I guess a certain level for a guy like you,
it's,
it becomes,
well you need a place to work out.
You don't need the money.
I don't need your 15 bucks or whatever.
So I don't mind doing it for free.
But when you were starting now and then you were just going all around New York,
that was how you were making a living.
Yeah,
that's the whole thing.
You're right Joe.
It's like,
it was like five big clubs and you would try and bounce from set to set to set
and do as many as manager can,
especially on the weekend.
And you,
you could rock out maybe 600 bucks,
you know,
a night.
So you'd be like,
Oh man,
this is,
I can't believe it.
I'm going to go.
But then you blast it all out on booze and Shit,
you know?
So it was like a,
you know,
net loss.
What's the most amount of sets you've ever done it in a night?
I think.
I know I don't hold the record for in New York City the most amount,
but uh,
I think the record is 13 to 15 with prom shows.
Cause during the prom season they would,
he's a ton of them,
but I think I've probably done like 10 to 12 in one night
I did a prom shows with auto and George.
Wow,
that's totally Alan Lubell.
Oh Man.
Really?
There were crazy because what they did was they never took anybody out.
So what they told you what they would recycle the Comedians,
you know,
you would do like a half an hour set.
I think it was a half an hour.
I'm pretty sure it was a good long set.
And then the other guy would go on after you and he would do half now and then
they'd have four people on the show and then they wanted you to come back on for
the next show.
And it was the exact same crowd.
Oh.
So what they said is you have to do the same material.
You have to do the same material because if you do,
yeah,
because if you do new material,
they're going to stay.
So even though you know it's the same crowd,
it was like they didn't even,
they didn't know who was who.
It was like a pigsty.
Like they push these pigs,
the sky,
they didn't know who was one from one show who was from another show.
So their way of dealing with all these unruly kids was to just keep pushing more
in there.
It was insane.
Total health code violations and the shows went all night.
You would do a show at 6:00 PM I did a,
me and auto and George did one once.
I remember we did a show and we started out at like you started out when it gets
dark and it was actually probably before it got dark and we were done at like
six in the morning.
Man.
It was like bright out when we left the club.
Well that's the beauty of it.
I can't believe.
You said you did prompt shows with auto and George.
Can you think of his last that's like,
it was awesome.
Filthy dirtiest and the puppet world is Hitler.
He is like fucking evil and these poor kids and he's 16 year old,
these twilight kids to come down and they're like getting old.
I can only amount the protein slurpee joke that really must have a hate hard
that night.
You know that's his blowjob material.
Yeah,
proteins.
Graham's got some,
he's got some great fucking lines.
I remembered the people don't get it though.
It's like it's not about him faking now.
He's really doing this.
His lips move man.
I mean he know.
He's like,
come on,
we playing games.
He knows the fucking puppet so he doesn't like do a good job of like,
so like these kids were yelling at
these dumb kids were like hassling him.
They weren't getting them.
The Majesty of the auto and George Experience,
they were too young.
They were too young and dumb.
They were like,
oh,
this guy's back and see his lips moving.
You know that?
That's so cool because in New York when we,
when we got that wave of like Boston guys like you,
uh,
Louis C K,
Nick Depalo,
you know,
that was like the beginning of like the new start of comedy.
Cause I remember like,
uh,
you know the old eighties comedy,
you know,
like a,
I'm not going to name names,
but it's just like all the sweater comics,
the guys who would come up there and with like a rap tunes,
here's my,
you know,
crazy rap too.
And then it was over.
They do some kind of like impression and that was a bill Cosby like,
yeah.
But then like when you guys came in then it became like the new wave of comedy
and that's,
that was,
that was cool.
That was really like when it started again,
I think,
you know,
while comedy was dead,
dead,
you know?
Yeah.
Well their key becomes waves when it becomes a community.
But we were the last guys from the Boston community really.
It was like burr and Patrice were like the last guy.
Yeah,
I know.
There's still some really funny guys.
They have been there and I've seen some of the funny up and coming guys,
but for whatever reason they're not getting the kind of attention that the
younger guys got.
You know,
back in the day it doesn't seem like the scene is,
is like dance to be.
Yeah.
Like Nick's comedy stop is kind of still around,
but stitches is gone and the,
you know,
the Improv is gone and duck soup to connection's gone.
The connections now a giant theater,
you know,
and so it's like guys are kind of forced.
I know Tim Mcintyre has a room somewhere in Faneuil hall.
I think it's a small room,
like a hundred seater.
I'm sure that's really good.
But,
and then there's a Chinese restaurant in Cambridge.
I did it once.
And then other than that,
it's like Boston's not,
it's not what it used to be.
It used to be,
man,
when I started out in the late eighties,
I started in 88 it was a hive man,
John.
Um,
Jonathan Katz was the host of the open mic night.
Tude Jonathan Katz brought me up for the first time on stage.
Brilliant comedian.
I got to see Teddy bears,
Ron when he was in its prime.
Wow.
You know,
do you know tests I did Teddy Berge on for ladies and gentlemen,
we won't know.
Might've been one of the most brilliant with the best timing.
I've never seen a comic with better timing than Teddy Berge.
Ron just casual,
relaxed.
He would hit the punchline and you would at one point you'd be laughing at
another point you'd be going,
God damn this motherfucker.
God Damn,
he's good.
I'll say that about the Boston guys.
Like you know,
cause I was a bunch of long island is that like the Boston guys are not only
fearless,
but they also were like intelligent and they could really quickly switch from
like rowdy drunk college crowd to like more of a sophisticated crowd.
Whereas on long island we were basically townie people,
you know,
and like,
uh,
there'll be like a couple of like,
you know,
like PG 13 acts.
But then the rest of us were like just dirty drunk,
you know,
kind of like county,
you know.
I think every community needs someone who's really good to show you how the fuck
to do it.
Oh yeah.
Boston had Steve Sweeney done.
Gavin,
Lenny Clarke,
legend,
legend Kenny Rogers,
and they just had all these animals.
Don Galvin was a fucking savage when he was younger.
Man.
Damn,
he was good.
The guys were like,
I dunno,
like gunfighters cause like as good as they were onstage,
offstage.
Jay were better in terms of like,
it was just like,
you know,
they were the real deal.
Listen,
there's only one way you get a comic like that.
You don't get a comic like that through yoga.
You get so fucking,
that's a guy who's living a real life.
I Lenny Clarke,
I fucking love Lenny Clarke.
He's like one of the funniest old school Boston guys and I got the chance to
work with him on this
movie.
He was telling me a story,
but my whole day's Joe back when I was doing blow.
He goes,
one day I woke up,
I was in the fucking Bahamas.
You just have no idea.
We got to The Bahamas.
I was not,
I was partying.
I was hanging out in New York.
Next thing you know,
boom.
In the fucking Bahamas.
I woke up,
I looked at the beach.
I thought I was on long island.
Oh,
that's so gross,
dude.
He's,
he's brilliant.
It's amazing.
Those guys were alive.
I mean it's just,
unfortunately it took it to a level.
Kevin Knox isn't,
we lost him recently.
He loved that guy.
He was another one,
another real wild,
fun guy.
We've lost so many great guys in the last three years.
I would say.
It's just a,
it's,
it's so sad and depressing and it's terrifying.
I don't know.
No,
you look good man.
You think he didn't work out?
I exercise and I take vitamins for important brand that brain healthy and the
brain stuff.
Brain pills and Alpha brain furious masturbation.
They say that that's the best way to keep your prostate healthy.
Do you think so?
Yeah.
Shooting loads.
That's when dudes,
the prostate starts rotting off.
Wow.
Stop shooting loads.
They think it's actually a preventative measure.
I'm usually like a two,
two a day guy.
You know,
they still wanting to get a sleep,
one to just be alive,
to be alive,
just to feel alive.
Nothing sexual,
just like,
am I?
Am I a cognizant person or if you wake up at nine and you want to get an extra
two hours sleep bang one off right there.
God tambien.
Yeah,
yeah.
I wonder if that works that way for women.
It doesn't seem,
it seems like it at all in orgasms they get energized.
Yes.
They want to go do something.
Yeah.
They want to just run around and fucking look at stuff.
I'm going to just amazing.
They beat us in every battle there is,
you know they have hearts,
they have,
they grow humans inside of them.
They have to be crafty and adaptable.
Yeah.
It's to take care of those little humans.
It's what it is,
but I do know that women like with the,
with the vibrators and I'm sure going to talk about it endlessly on that because
your crowd is cool.
You know?
Sometimes like I'll talk about vibrators onstage and I was like,
you feel like the people tighten up and you're like,
am I,
is this like the scarlet letter or something?
Am I,
is this like a puritan community here?
It's like vibrator.
You know it.
They're like selling them at like Dwayne Reed or cvs now.
It's not like it's a big,
you have to go into like a shack and see,
you see a guy with an eyepatch,
what are you looking forward?
They're like right out there,
but people are like,
Ooh,
you know,
whatever.
It's a funny thing,
man.
It's a funny thing to be embarrassed about.
You know?
I think it's ridiculous.
Yeah.
All sex toys and all that stuff.
It's funny.
It's a funny thing to be embarrassed about beating off,
you know,
being embarrassed about sex.
Really.
I've been using my girlfriend has is I'll wage masturbate lately.
Really?
You just do it so quick and you're like,
dude,
that's just like,
I just masturbated using her as well.
You're being rude like that.
I don't know what I,
I've been a horrible person lately.
Really?
Yeah.
Do you get,
do you get lazy when it comes to sex and I'm just so tired and so much.
Yeah,
you got to fuck girls correctly and I didn't want to keep them around.
That's what I've found.
I think it's very important to never do that.
It's very important to and less and less like they don't want to wake up and
like,
cause there's some sleep issue.
They go go ahead and stick it in real quick and you're like,
all right,
cool.
But it's gotta be like an agreement.
Otherwise you're going to have problems when he can't just dump inside of her.
I just rollover.
Right.
Is that what you're doing?
Yeah,
pretty much.
I mean,
I mean like I'm like I've upgraded from the fleshlight to using my girlfriend.
Meanwhile his girlfriend is super hot.
I can't believe it.
Stupid hot dude.
There's something about red heads.
They are just so you want to bite him,
bite him,
right?
Yeah.
That's all I want to bite redheads.
I do.
Yeah.
You want to bite them?
I want to choke them.
I want to,
I like how,
like you're,
you're a guy who knows his history,
how,
like back in the day the red head was like a sign of like,
you know,
whatever.
The apocalypse wasn't really,
and now it's like the sign of a really cool time,
you know,
on a check.
Got It.
Dude.
It's hard to,
well,
Lou pulls it off.
Well,
Louise,
a redhead and bill burr who was on my arm,
Dave's all porn show.
He's ready to have a red head,
but he's more kind of a brown haired guy.
It's,
he's not quite a red head.
He looks a little Kris kringle Lee lately.
He's like,
really?
Yeah.
Sam is else,
you know,
he's adorable.
He always looks like he's like 28 or older than that,
but slow.
It's like whatever.
He's like,
he's hilarious.
Yeah.
We were real lucky.
Like we were talking about,
you know,
being in Boston,
you had that environment where you got to be influenced and inspired by so many
really good guys.
But New York had a bunch of fucking good guys too,
dude.
But in Long Island didn't,
not so much.
Right.
The guy's like auto and George was absolutely brilliant.
Well they were,
those doers are a few of those guys that would be the road guys.
Like I don't always struck me as something different than some of those guys
because a lot of those guys there would be kind of like getting by but just real
hacky,
just doing what they could do to get through this stage with Otto.
It was like he was making art out of being the filthiest Ooh,
horrible things.
Just the filthiest possible but art,
but brilliant.
You know,
but you cry laughing.
Yeah.
He's definitely a one of a kind and and like,
um,
uh,
watch for call it,
who is the prop guy,
you know?
Um,
countertop,
not carrots up the other guy.
Um,
great evil prop dude.
Oh,
you know what I'm talking about?
Shit,
Shit.
He's another guy who always pleased jersey.
Really cool.
Like,
like chip,
chip Cooney and those kind of guys are like classic Vaudevillian type evil,
you know,
like Coppola esque acts,
but on long island,
this Jerry Seinfeld,
Kevin James,
you know,
and then a couple of other really good guys.
There was a lot of guys like me,
but I really like started in New York City,
like,
oh,
the open mic scene there for years and years and years.
So you lived in Long Island and you community not to stand up?
Oh No.
I went to Nyu and I,
and I,
uh,
stayed in the city,
but I would go out to the island to do road gigs.
And the first one Gig I ever did was in queens with Adam Sandler.
And we did a disco and he brought me along because we both went to Nyu and he
brought me along and I totally tanked it.
And then we,
you know,
the old,
we're standing under the disco ball as we're circled by these,
you know,
basically Guido's,
and they're circling us.
And uh,
he totally killed and you know,
he was just like,
he knew what he wanted to do immediately,
you know,
like he was an actor,
he was a comic and all that kind of stuff.
And I catch a rising star.
He was the golden child.
Honestly.
He was the first guy to make it on to MTV and then SNL and all that kind of
stuff.
And uh,
you know,
Colin Quinn,
who is at bigger moments on anybody who's was in that era.
And like in New York,
he totally like a,
you know,
basically there was like a cool scene there of where you could see guys do
different,
different things.
But I always slept.
Boston guys definitely came in hard,
able to do the road like right away.
Whereas us like meek little like New York guys,
you know,
it'd be like 45 minutes.
Holy Shit.
We got used to doing half hour and a horrible boss environment.
We did a lot of crazy gigs.
That was,
but there was so many of them.
The beautiful thing about being in Boston as you could make a living,
I mean,
I was in comedy a year and I started making,
you know,
a couple of hundred bucks a week.
And today that's really hard to do.
Yeah,
it's really hard to pull any money out and after a year's worth of comedy.
But in Boston there were so many gigs you could,
you could mc these gigs.
Like Lenny Clarke took me on the road.
I am seed for him.
You know,
you just do an opening set,
just trying to try and get the crowd warmed up.
Everybody wants someone to do that and they'll pay you 50 bucks,
they'll pay 100 bucks and next thing you know you're actually making a hundred,
you know,
50 bucks a night,
$200 a night sometimes.
Absolutely.
So when I came to New York and I was like,
what I gotta do sets for free and that can only do like 10 minutes or something
like that.
And I'm like,
fuck this.
I'm going to get,
I'll just drive to New Jersey.
So it was just drive to New Jersey.
I do sets there.
I drive to Connecticut.
I did a lot of sets and Connecticut,
John Schuler Gigs.
You ever do those gigs?
He had them all over the past.
It was crazy.
You know,
one of those like,
uh,
you know,
here's the thing,
you Joe,
you're like pure,
like really good to comedy is like the thing that really now that I'm all,
they've been doing it like 26 years.
The thing that really bothers me the most is that these guys that I know that I
bring out on the road that are headline,
headline and quality,
you know,
some of them have credits,
some of them don't.
It's like they're not going to be able to headline even like a B room until like
to get a TV show.
And that's what sucks because I was like headline and for years and years and
years before I was a even like,
you know,
a whatever,
a name.
And it was great because like nobody really knew me and it was really just me
like learn the headline and that was cool.
Now it's like you need like a TV show or you need like,
you know,
pocket.
Well who even knows
and what he's saying is he didn't need anything back then.
He neither,
he nor I.
All we had was like a little credits.
I had like Mtvs had comedy hour and I would headline all over the country.
It's really,
you can't really do that anymore
in an hour.
Special teams,
nothing,
you know,
cause the club owners and I get their deal,
I get it.
They got to fill these seats.
You've got,
you know it's a business.
But like for these younger guys who like I bring out and I'm like this guy is
blowing me off the stage.
He should be headlining.
And like I'll go to the club owner,
like you must have a slow week somewhere.
Like you're bringing these guys,
I'm like working out and they're like,
you know what?
We never,
we can't afford to do anymore.
We got to always
be making money.
So that really sucks about comedy now I really hate it.
But the win for these young guys is like,
I don't know,
there's some in the water pipe but just self promotion,
always self promoting friends checks.
I don't know what to tell you.
There are talking to themselves up.
We have a couple friends that are brilliant that have had those problems.
Are Is your fear,
right?
A Duncan Trussell,
Joey Diaz,
those are the three of my friends that have had their,
their brilliant comedians and they've had that problem with the podcast is
straight and all that shit out.
Chill.
We got a fucking standing ovation in Buffalo.
He got on stage and he got a standing ovation.
They know who the fuck he is.
It's the podcast.
That's why I did death squad transfer.
All my friends that all these guys that don't get TV credits,
they get commercials once in a while and then next thing you know,
because of the podcast,
because of the Internet,
those guys,
they get developed a huge following and it's like,
and they all the sudden they go from,
I can't get work anywhere to like Ari's work in pretty much every weekend.
Our,
he's like,
he's all over the place.
So he's a great guy too.
I seen him at the comedy store all the time and,
and you know,
he does it right because he's always trying out new shit down there.
He's a writer and he's pushing it and that's what that club especially in my
mind is for.
You know,
it's just to like constantly be working on new shit.
So yeah,
there's no industry there.
But that was always the thought about the stores.
You can go crazy at the store.
Like they would say,
don't do the,
we got some new dirty bit you're working on.
Don't do it at the Improv cause what does it,
what if it bombs and what have some of the importance and the crowd.
Yes,
that happens man.
If someone sees you,
I got to seat people see me when I was starting out where really no one should
have ever seen me and they never raised that memory,
that memory of shit.
It doesn't matter how you kill and your next special,
doesn't matter how honed you have your hour,
it's just they remember that time you ate a dick at the laugh factory.
I love the memory too.
And it's always like if you're,
if you're not hip to the fact that there are industry people,
and I like,
that's the cool thing about New York.
There's none of that shit.
You know,
maybe some guy will come up to you afterwards.
Like,
I own a beefsteak Charlie's somewhere.
I want you to come down and do a bachelor party.
It'll be a fun time,
you know,
like some weird set up.
But here it's like every,
every person in the crowd has something to do with show business and like you're
looking at might become someone.
So,
but I mean,
you never know when someone's in the crowd.
That could be just someone's assistant.
And next thing you know,
five years later they're the head of some studio and they,
I remember when you ate shit on stage at the comedy store at about one in the
morning,
you ain't shit on stage.
They're like,
oh,
I did.
I had some writers from news radio come to see me once.
And it was a long set in the main room.
And truth be told I wasn't that good back then anyway.
I mean I just,
I don't have been doing comedy for six years or something like that.
Seven years.
It was,
it.
I wasn't that good.
I just,
I,
I had sloppy nights,
so like I could have nights where I nailed it,
but then I would have a night where I just fucking completely fell off the
tracks and into the woods and I don't know what went wrong.
You know?
That's how it is.
When you first started out,
the first seven,
one of those nights where we said that Richard Lewis and somebody the first
seven years or like the the hardest,
you know,
and I'll,
I'll,
I'll push that back to the first 10.
Honestly,
the first 10 years just suck.
Yeah.
Is fucking hard.
It's hard to figure out what the hell.
I did my first CD after 11 years in it and I'm super glad that I waited that
long.
Cool.
That's cool.
Yeah.
Well it didn't have any,
it's not like I had a lot of people beating down my door to do a CD.
It was actually my idea to try to put it together.
So I was just lucky though,
because I could have released something earlier and it would have been a piece
of shit.
You know,
and I've,
I've listened to some old recordings of myself and it's like,
I wouldn't even want to pull them on line is a goof fucking door like Stan hope
did it.
He's brave.
Stan hope to put like some videos of his like first year on stage.
He's my guy.
Love.
There's no when there's no,
no in that guy.
He's just amazing.
He's like a cool,
like when you listen to you,
you're like your shit.
Cause I think growing up that was how I,
that's how I fell in love with comedy.
It was like listen to cds and ray and a watchman call it just like the five
o'clock funnies,
whatever they had back then.
And just like albums and like every time I see a standup special,
you know,
it's like the same shit.
Some poor dude up there trying to like,
you know,
milk,
the labs and he looks so not having fun and it's like such a set up thing.
It's like nobody can ever recapture like the Richard Pryor error of like,
you know,
he's wasted.
The crowds wasted fucking rambling.
And every word ever in his fucking mouth is like a delicious fucking Angel Fart
of just like wisdom,
you know.
Do you ever hear the old those Richard Pryor tapes?
There was a gas station that was selling these tapes near my house,
a gas station and little box of cassettes they would sell.
And somehow or another,
this guy was selling these Richard Pryor tapes.
So I,
I bought a bunch of them.
Man,
I forget,
like it was like Richard Fox,
uh,
Richard prior to Red Fox theater.
I think that's what it was.
It was like red files,
this club.
I've heard bits of that.
I haven't heard like reg red Foxx is nightclub.
He's just up there talking shit.
Just high as fuck talking shit.
And every other word out of his mouth was just a jam to gem.
But the crowds were so cool.
They were like there for the party.
Yeah.
It's like everybody's so like hyper aware of themselves and like they're so
afraid to laugh at fucking anything.
You know?
There's a lot of that,
but there's a lot of cool people out there too.
It's just got to figure out how to attract only them.
Well you have a cool audience.
I mean honestly I don't know how I pulled it up cooler for a cooler crowd.
No,
and you play like some really cool off the wall venues and that that's,
that's what it's about.
You know,
I always hear from waitresses and it's one of the coolest things ever.
I always hear from waitresses that my people are nice and generous.
Yeah,
she goes tippers.
I love that.
That is,
to me that is the ultimate compliment that somehow or another of of of
accumulated a bunch of Nice people and unless the the greatest thing that could
ever pull off.
Oh they love it.
Like when your crowd good drunk,
it's like my crowd was like master drunk.
They know what the fuck do you do it and was another little kids.
He's the first person I talked to do standup because of that.
It really being a the insomnia show and he caught me.
I recording him cause I didn't,
I never went to a comedy show so I didn't know like what do you like?
I was using the bands always try to sneak my camcorder
in and try to take like a clip or something so I'm going to be $8 according to
in it on stage.
The videos,
him pointing at me,
he goes,
hey,
you know what,
the camera,
I turned out
I wanted to bring that clip.
I forgot them should have brought that probably was fatter and just like all
puffy.
I love that.
Like 20 pounds of booze on you.
The puffiness.
It's really not the booze,
it's the Burger and fries and more fries.
And then of course you got to have a piece of cake.
Yeah.
You know,
porn for your stomach.
Oh,
after gigs,
man,
I eat like several people.
Would I do a two show Saturday night,
Brian?
I'll tell ya,
he rested ridiculous amounts of food where people,
they don't even,
didn't only think I'm being honest,
the waitress three times give me two entrees.
I want a steak and I want a chicken.
I'll wait to,
it's always the leaves
like you're like,
I'm not done.
And then I order stupid amounts of food after gigs.
Ma'Am.
What's your like,
what's your like fucking guilty but what's your like waffles swap after the
sheriff.
Fuck,
I love options.
Would crazy amounts of butter on them,
dude.
Just Slatter that shit and butter cover that motherfucker.
Maple Syrup and I'm not really down with those Belgium waffles.
I like the waffles they give you when you go to Roscoe's.
Roscoe's chicken and Waffles,
they have the thin waffles that then rifles are the real deal.
Those big stupid Belgium waffles.
Those puffy fucking stupid waffles did too much.
That's it.
That's all you got.
I'll take the Belgium waffle,
but God,
goddammit.
Regular waffles or better.
What's your stays?
What's your night?
I was like,
well you know,
cause I always professional drunk so it'd be like a,
you know,
lots of me.
I needed to me to like fight the booze and my stomach,
but it always came up like,
you know,
shitting blood and just horrible fucking just like how many times you shed
blood.
I'll tell you like I've shipped blood for weeks
and then I've shipped to,
you know,
be like you don't have healthcare so you gotta kind of like do your own
analysis,
taste it.
I don't know if it's too sweet.
I do my own kind of,
maybe I need less oranges in my diet,
but a,
I'm like,
you know,
all those horrible experiences,
but I definitely meet was the thing that would help me fucking fight the booze.
But I'll tell you like now that like I don't drink,
there's something about cake that like,
it's like pussy,
you know,
it's like,
like you'll stare at it and like try not to be,
you know,
like let it know that you love it.
Do you try to eat healthy?
I'm trying to eat like a,
which we call it,
you know like oatmeal cause like oatmeal.
It's like this like when to hit like I'm 46 so they'll like,
oh meal,
I'll take,
you know,
we'll help you.
I was like,
nothing's going to fucking help them.
Chain smoking,
drinking black fucking coffee here.
Like coffee's good for,
this is fucking great copy.
Is it really from all,
it's Kona coffee.
I love this shit.
Is stopping drinking,
help the blood,
like he's still bleed now.
I only bleed for the economy.
Good job troops for Joe.
I believe for the troops and the economy.
We know jobs.
When you,
um,
you know,
you just sort of let it stop bleeding.
No,
it just,
you know,
whatever.
I don't know you're wrong.
I'm a blood brother.
I did the same thing.
My body,
it happens for weeks for me to honestly,
I mean,
I'm,
some days I'm still alive and like the fact that like,
you know,
I'm so self destructive like my mother,
like she's such a sweetheart,
like,
you know,
I kinda like,
we're responsible for her.
So that's what the only thing that keeps me from like crossing that line of
like,
you know,
like fuck yeah,
I'm going to huff paint and you know,
the dual,
that kind of stuff.
I mean,
because honestly,
you know,
when you're a comic and you're out there balls deep in the road,
it's like,
do you really care?
You know,
it's like you just looking for the next fucking wild.
This tonight.
It's fun,
it's fun now it's,
yeah,
now whatever.
It's fun to have a bunch of shots with some people and kind of do my five and
the problem is the next,
oh yeah.
And that's the problem.
But then now you get older,
right?
And like you got a mortgage and you've got to do,
you know,
you got kids and everything like that.
It's like,
ah,
I just wished boots didn't do any damage.
I wish booze was like weed or you did it.
You never felt the next day,
you're fine.
Well,
because we're Americans
do,
you know,
we fucking work hard and we drink hard and we,
and we,
and we're like,
fuck you,
we have the right to do it.
I know it was your reengineer booze.
You know,
some scientists need to get on this whole Buddhist thing and figure out,
give me the effects of booze,
you know,
make it tastes like booze.
But figuring out a way where it doesn't wreck your system.
There's gotta be a way to recreate being drunk without testing,
without making you just poisoned,
you know,
I mean really,
we're so retarded.
We go poison each other
like so many good effects for it.
But it was never my drug.
But I like,
I totally,
I'm like,
we're all like or don't like it rather Stan hope doesn't like it.
Yeah,
no we were boozing and like,
you know drug guys,
we weren't about the weed that you didn't like.
Well no offense,
but I thought it was kind of prissy.
I always thought it was a sit around and like there's something about weed and
like sitting on a couch and then all of a sudden there's a guitar there for some
reason and then now you're hearing a million parodies or you're hearing a
million fucking days and everyone's giggling.
And then me,
if you're around,
if you're hanging around with idiots and they get high,
you're in for some profound stupidity.
But I think it facilitates thinking.
Definitely a lot of people don't like it cause it makes you paranoid though.
Cause it can.
It's if you're not into that,
if you're not in
can out yourself,
it can fuck with you.
Well,
Dr Drew,
you know,
not to bring it up.
I love toxin germs.
No.
Okay.
Well just the Rehab Rehab I've watched a few times because just to go whoa,
well like they had a guy on there,
I'm not going to say whatever movie,
sorry.
It was like his vaporizing pot and like,
oh yeah.
Not say his name.
Eric.
Robert.
Okay.
Eric Roberts.
So I don't know if he's done the podcast or not,
but we have on the podcast by the code,
you know,
whatever.
Pick up my fucking thumbs.
Charlie.
He's the most,
he's the most celebrity to be rehabbed in my mind.
I'm like,
yeah,
that's an amazing actor.
If that's all he's doing,
so be it.
It's La,
he's an actor getting high.
It's like,
you know,
isn't that part of the think?
That was just a shit career move.
It was just a terrible move.
I
mean,
come on.
He's saying that he's got an addiction to pod.
That's so just stop smoking pot.
Yeah.
Everybody's shaking their all shitting blood.
It's like reading the papers,
drinking a cup of coffee.
It was like nothing was wrong with,
this is one guy that doesn't have a problem.
They showed him vaporizing in this beautiful bathroom in this house.
Like that's not the sign of a drug addict.
Okay.
That's like should be like an a shack.
The trailer park.
It's just silly.
So whatever.
But uh,
but it's a different effect.
It's not that freewheeling carefree.
I don't give a fuck effect that alcohol is alcohol.
I like,
I liked that.
I've looked at Brian and I like it.
We've,
you know,
when we go out and we'd do a weekend at a club somewhere for,
and it's always the question you want to do a shot?
And I don't think he said no one's ever said no.
Probably be too drunk.
Done into stoned.
Definitely.
It's,
it's too stoned to me.
It's like a heart,
a heart attack.
I can't think of anything straight.
I can't even make sentences drunk is like,
I could probably get through drawing.
I agree with you.
But I liked that experience because I always learned something about myself from
it.
Whenever I have bad trips,
whenever I go too deep into the rabbit hole,
I always come out of it with a good knowledge of whatever is fucking with me.
Yeah.
Because sometimes the way to look at it,
sometimes you,
sometimes you can put shut off,
you know there's things that you,
you,
you really need to be concentrating on.
You don't go out,
you know,
and then you don't realize how much your,
how much it's in the back of your hand until you have like some crazy Brownie
high where you get way too scared and nervous and then you start realizing
yourself,
like the full reality of all,
you're the way you're thinking and all your weird experiences and how you
process them and couldn't really mind.
Fuck the shit out of you.
And it's not comfortable,
man.
It doesn't feel good at all.
But when it's over you go,
oh,
okay,
I see what's wrong with me now.
I see what's,
what's been bugging me now.
I see.
You know?
But then pushing to the back of my head,
don't you feel it like a comedy,
which is like an ultimate like especially when you're first starting out,
when you suck and you're really standing in front of a group of people who
smelled blood in the water.
Oh Shit.
Blood.
I'm talking about like there's like a weak fucking animal rip it apart and like
that's,
you're never as alive as you are in that moment.
That's addictive to me at least.
Is that that moment of like where you're like one against many,
you know,
outnumbered out.
I used to get off on that.
Booze was really just a side sidetrack.
But you've been in like experienced.
Especially like with fighting,
you know it's like he can't like the high,
the intensity of that.
It's very hard thing.
That's why guys keep coming back.
You know,
even guys like sugar ray Leonard kept boxing like way past his prime and a lot
of their old,
they all do.
They all come back and they get fucked up and you know,
it's like a story as old as time.
It's cause they,
the,
the addiction of being out there and winning and just the high of the
experience.
And then when it's over there,
their definition,
their self definition is all based on their fighting.
You know,
like this is the classic example of the old fighter that it's always,
you know,
telling war stories,
reminding everybody about what he did and how annoying everybody thinks that
shit is.
They don't want to hear that.
Back on 69 I was fighting Mickey,
you know,
you know those guys,
and why is that guy that like I somehow or another,
his life went from being this wild ride of intense experiences,
too mundane nothingness.
Every day he's doing nothing.
Every day he's seeing his kids and every day he's getting the paper and every
day he's nothing.
He's not a fighter anymore.
It doesn't have this intense life.
And he's addicted to like this super high frequency of life.
So they go,
you know what?
I'm going to give it a comeback.
I've been,
they'd get up and training.
I dropped 20 pounds,
I'm gonna run around the block.
They just want to have that intense experience again,
that's like a regular lifestyle enough.
That's what I think like,
especially with,
I know you've got a lot of like bedrooms,
a lot of that's coming up by the way,
veterans day.
And uh,
I've done some shows,
Uso tours and stuff like that.
And I see the look in the,
in these young kids eyes who definitely have been like,
you know,
in combat rotated many,
many times.
They come back here and it's all surreal for them,
you know,
whether they're,
uh,
you know,
just like walking down the street,
whatever.
It's got to be such a real adjustment that like none of us could ever
understand.
But I will tell you what comedy that like once you,
everybody thinks they're a comic,
but once you like drink the fucking lifestyle,
like when the lifestyle is like,
we,
like,
you only feel comfortable hanging out at a comedy club,
you know,
that's like,
it's like,
it's like your secret garden.
That's when you know,
you're like,
you're never gonna go.
It's not like your parents are always like,
maybe you'll go back to school and it's like fuck that.
That's never going to happen.
I'm never going to whatever.
And you know the fact that I'm the biggest loser loser in the family yet,
you know,
I pay the mortgage,
they're like pretty stoked about that.
So you know,
you know,
I was like I'm the most uneducated fucking zero,
whatever my family but still like,
you know,
kick in and do my part.
So,
uh,
I'll just say that like the lifestyle is the fucking addiction and the comedy is
like the,
you know,
is the gravy cause uh,
doing the shows,
man,
it's fucking,
I wouldn't trade even a bad one for,
for the experience.
I'll tell you that like looking back in hindsight,
like the bad ones were like lessons you needed.
The good ones were like just fucking jerk and off cause the bad ones were like
fucking hard,
hard lessons.
Like,
like Batman on ice when it had a fight.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
These are a few that really stand out.
I've got some with some bombs like from my past where it just still to this day
I just go,
Oh God,
yeah,
like brushing my teeth in 2011 thinking about a,
said I had 92 and just go
fuck.
I ate some dick up there.
I would be like,
I would walk out of the theater and like nobody,
no eye contact,
you know the,
Oh,
let's route it.
And then you'd walk out and you're like,
please,
some kind of automobile hit me.
Or it's just something,
something horrible softball,
more horrible thing to think about.
But yeah,
people don't know that.
I'd have no idea what the experience of bombing feels like.
I always say it's like sucking a thousand Dick's in front of your
mother.
It's probably worse.
It's probably worse than that because somewhere out there someone would like to
suck a thousand Dixon Front.
It was the ultimate naughty thing and amazing race.
That would be cool.
I think a thousand dicks.
It's almost so it's like,
when do you like,
I'm sorry mom,
it's like a hot dog eating contest,
but without the,
you know,
you definitely don't do it outdoors.
People don't gather going to be dicks would get rancid.
It wouldn't be good.
By the time he got to him,
there's no countdown either
998.
You lose track.
How many loads of I swag speaking of porn,
speaking to porn,
your show man,
Dave's old porn on showtime.
So what,
what does this show?
What's going on in your watch porn and you just goof on it.
Yeah,
it's the mystery science theater of porn
kicking this idea for like four or five years.
And uh,
you know,
uh,
finally found the place that it's cool enough to let us do it.
Showtime.
And,
uh,
I came up with the idea with Stuart Bailey,
who's a exact on another TV show and we just been like,
you know,
having a ball,
like working the comics,
gray comics on it.
And uh,
just like legends of Porn,
you know,
porn is better if not as well as me.
And you're a man over here.
And I was a tons of porn,
you know,
like Seiko who like growing up like you know Uber Goddess.
I always thought she was like some German like being a Jew.
I'm a Jew.
Okay.
Like this is like so like blonde fucking super hot Uber fucking chick.
She's like,
you know,
she's a country girl from Kansas.
I'm not going to say exactly where she's from,
but she's like,
you know,
it's a regular chick,
Nina Hartley who was the kind of a crossover but yet very,
very sweaty.
The comedy store.
I'm very nice lady.
Very cool.
And then of course Ron Jeremy,
who was like,
you know,
everybody's a porn star and millennium.
Can you remember the first time you met someone in person that you had beaten
off to?
Who?
Ron.
Jeremy?
No,
no,
it was Doris as forwarding.
The worst is when you,
you recognize a guy's Dick.
That's when you know you've seen too much for Peter North.
You're like,
oh Jesus Christ,
the fuck is wrong with me.
I'm recognizing dude's dicks.
You know,
just free HD,
little tiny fucking
foreign screen.
This is like a,
the thing about it is like I've jerked off to all of them and like,
like you know,
there was the jerking off from when I was just like a guy jerking off.
Like any guy out there like let's jerk off.
And then there was like the research for the show jerk off you sitting in my
apartment with hundreds of classic Retro Harry Porn tapes and like watching,
watching,
watching and then like going like,
okay,
we're going to have to like take a break.
And like,
I'd have to like shoot like this massive,
like my dick was owed.
Like my Dick had been so good dog.
You know,
my Dick had led me and all the right directions and then to finally got a chance
to hold the ball,
you know?
Oh my God.
It was like,
I just have to have to,
you know the,
so you watched all this stuff just hours watching it hours.
Yeah.
Wow.
That must be a mind fuck.
Well it was just weird to just have piles of porn.
Like everybody,
that was always my big joke.
The duffle bag full of VHS porn,
you know,
moving from one apartment to the next one.
Like
did anybody order a sad sailor?
You know,
the new roommate.
Gulp,
what's this guy going to be like?
But uh,
you know,
uh,
I love tape
you saying,
I can tell you I like it better than the downloads and under the downloads it's
killing porn,
but you know,
who can,
who can afford it?
You to tape slugger CD's,
a CD,
you know,
like a CD,
DVD,
whatever.
But I used to have the old VHS VHS tapes,
so my mom's laws,
the machine.
So,
you know,
sometimes we will watch together.
Horn guys were always coming to the comedy store,
handing out DVDs.
There's no weird porn dudes.
Yeah,
it's hard being a dude in point.
It really is like the unsung hero really.
Before Viagara Ron Jeremy said it on his show with Whitney Cummings.
He was like,
you know,
there's only like 10 guys who could do this without,
by Agra.
You know,
it's like you really had to like love to be a zen master,
like,
and to come when they want you in August.
So that was like back in the day.
Now it's like,
you know there's a lot of enhancement.
There's a lot of training.
They squeeze their balls to try to keep like men can do like kegels sorta like
girls.
If you really want to become a professional and you sit around and just you know
that you think of squeezing your deck,
think I'm just right now I'm doing it to ready you.
Just like a count of 20 like where are you squeezing?
Like Paul area you bought like from the tank top?
Yeah,
from the tank top.
Just trying to squeeze that whole area.
They get about the same muscles that you would use.
You try not to Piss your pants
and you do that man.
Do that for like 20 seconds.
Do Reps of 20 you've got to get real Zan with that.
Do you ever like hang a weight on your cock?
I'm like trying to do the whole like,
Oh I haven't done that yet.
Yeah,
that's,
that was worry that that would rip it or,
yeah,
or just terrify bar.
Have you heard about silicone that that guys have been shooting in their dicks
for us?
I saw one guy,
oh,
to make it look bigger or younger.
Silicone was a salient salient or something to make it look younger.
Make it look,
because that's what women want.
A younger looking deck
it way it gives the age away.
The ball sack is the definite pin code on your cock.
So it's like,
it's not exactly,
exactly Hanson,
but it's time it comes out.
If you got to that point,
it's going to get buried,
going to get buried somewhere.
Don't worry about it.
But these guys,
they,
they shoot it into their balls.
Was it Saint Lena?
Was it silicone?
It might have been.
So I'm known as silicon,
but they did his balls became this big giant like floppy sort of water bag
thing.
It's like almost like,
uh,
like uh,
like the inside of a water bed or something.
It was like sloshy you know,
and his Dick was all sloshy.
It was really weird.
It was like everything was big and fat and plump.
I love oddities.
That would be like a good,
like a mystery.
Like what else?
Kelsey shows,
you know,
oddities,
you know the ones where it's like I didn't know I was pregnant and the girl wore
coat and her house for like nine months.
It shows and showtime allowing you to show penetration and things like that.
They cover it up with like a green screen type thing where they have
like their couch sitting.
You know I use the couch was very much like mystery science theater kind of
where they do a lot.
It's the same five clips of it.
But once they started actually penetrating,
you don't show that.
We show tits,
tits,
we show actual when I want to show much penis cause all that was the one of the
very cool,
cause there's a lot of fans of this stuff there and I don't know this stuff half
as well as these guys do like a retro stuff,
you know and they're like,
you know,
I want to see more dick or whatever.
I would love to show gay.
Like I think all porn is the same.
You know what I'm saying?
It's all good.
You know,
it's all fighting the fight,
the good fight,
but it's like they're like,
we want to see more peanuts,
but they have a thing about pain.
Is there like on,
I think on all premium channels,
you know,
like you're allowed to show more hooch then you are a penis for some reason.
I don't know who digs her offensive.
Well,
yeah,
well dicks are ugly as you said,
but yeah,
they're just fucking fantastically whatever.
But I guess the penis,
you know,
whatever you're allowed to show for like a second.
But the hood,
she could show there's more area of the vagina that a,
especially if it's incredibly hairy and these boxes are like fucking wow.
Like pulling Hussein out of that hole.
The spider hole.
That's like that.
Every,
every time I would see one of these porn,
I'm like,
we got them.
I mean,
Joe,
I don't know if you guys like Harry and Harry,
I had already bought,
I don't like that idea.
I dealt with those young,
not your girl.
Your girl has gotta be like cleaning the for for work right now.
But I like having a look,
a little patch.
I got the girls,
I just shave it all the time.
I don't like that.
I like it.
Maybe once every three weeks you have a little patch or something.
You know?
Isn't it funny that the intense violence they show on a network like showtime on
a regular basis?
Like Riddick?
Like did you see the movie drive?
Yeah,
they'll probably show that uncut on showtime.
Right.
That was incredibly violent fucking movie.
Right?
Some of those scenes.
Yeah.
There were some scenes that were pretty deep.
That scene in the elevator with Oh God.
Yeah,
it's really intense.
It's showtime would play it because it's like check them.
They won't show Dix.
Well,
I think it has to do with this like some kind of standard thing.
But Dexter,
which is like a really cool serial killers,
like you're seeing like a disempowerment.
So,
but we're Americans,
so like we're were into violence.
But the sex thing is like,
it's amazing.
It's amazing how intense the violence can get and everybody's cool with it.
It's never enough.
Right.
The next movie always has to have more fucking,
you know,
beheadings and shit like that.
That's why overseas,
like when you go overseas,
you,
you've done like shows in England and all that kind of stuff.
They have this impression office of like this is a gun fucking nuts.
You know,
I love guns personally.
I respect them and I think everybody should be able to laugh at one.
But I agree.
It's like over you go overseas and then they'll like,
you know,
you cow boy blah blah blah blah blah.
And they try to imitate our movies with their Shitty,
you know,
whatever,
stories.
And I'm like,
dude,
you know,
I wish America was as cool as you see in these movies cause it ain't to strip
mall.
All right.
It's a petty cure.
Fucking strip mall.
Fucking Sam's Club.
It's not Stallone and Cobra.
It's none of that dude.
It's no hanging off the skid steer,
the helicopter Red Dawn.
It's fucking,
yeah,
it's really pretty tame here.
Yeah.
But most of them,
the countries you go to,
like they do,
they look at you like you've done something in America.
It's most countries hate us right now.
It's,
it's Kinda,
I mean,
not us,
but hate what this,
you know,
as a unit is doing
well.
That's why whenever you go overseas,
you know,
like a,
some guys would go like,
if it gets really bad,
pretend you're Canadian.
I'm like,
no,
I'm going to do that.
It gets really bad.
That's like,
I'm not going to do that.
And it's been fucking go head to head with this Moroccan kid who's fucking,
you know,
I'm going to go balls deep with it.
I'm going to fucking not pull back on that.
I mean,
honestly,
I like how they always like make us like we the creator of evil.
And it's like,
it's like you talked to some guy from Holland and it's like,
didn't you start slavery?
I mean,
honestly,
you know,
we're pretty dumb in America,
but really doing,
what are you the first guys to do it?
I think everybody's towards your goal or something.
You know?
What are they all do in slavery?
I mean,
who we just did a better and longer.
That was the problem.
You know,
you gotta like get out and get out early.
How long did the Romans do it for?
Oh,
I dunno,
but I was,
I mean,
have there been periods where there was slavery in the,
no.
Slavery.
How,
how's that work?
We're all slaves now too.
Or debit cards or,
I mean,
that's fucking caught him up right now.
Yeah.
I mean,
when,
you know,
when slaves are fed,
and they're housed.
Um,
and when you look at someone who gets minimum wage and you look at that,
like you cannot even feed you in housing.
Like you might've been better off being a slave if you could quit.
Right?
I mean,
if you like the weekend,
yeah,
you could be a slave.
Like,
but as long as they're not mean to you and they just feed you and make you work,
it's almost like they have,
they're just giving you a job because most people can't even feed themselves and
how's themselves for what they're getting paid.
I obviously,
it's worse to be a slave because you don't have a choice,
you know?
But it's really crazy when you think of the idea that you can have someone work
for 40 hours in a week and they can't even have a roof over their heads.
They can't even,
they'll work all day long and what their,
their physical presence is worth is not even enough to sustain it.
So fucking true.
I was thinking about it the other day,
how like 40 hour week was like what everybody was taught in this country.
Anybody who's doing 40 hours,
that's the minimum people will work in 50 everything he can.
Yeah.
Whatever.
And,
and,
and that's because like whatever,
like my brother's a pilot,
he makes like 12 bucks an hour.
You know,
when,
whenever your mind pilot,
he's an airline pilot,
12 bucks for a bigger line,
but a regional airlines and like stolen.
It's like,
you know,
it's like,
he's like almost an astronaut dude.
You know,
he's like her dead people's lives,
his thing.
And he's like,
you know,
they're always a cutting back on their pensions and you know,
the pilots
paid so little,
I don't know,
pilots would be someone who you'd want to really fucking take.
Exactly.
Especially like,
since like the turnover is,
is like,
you know,
they don't get enough rest and they don't get doors.
So it's amazing the disparity in terms of like income for some people,
whatever.
And same thing with teachers.
Like I got come from like,
you know,
parents who are teachers and they treat them like shit.
And honestly,
I mean,
you got kids,
you know how it is.
It's like,
you know,
it's day to day grind,
trying to keep your kids on the right path and these people have to do it every
day.
A lot of kids come from a lot of different backgrounds and they've got to Meld
that together into a class and they get,
you know,
everybody's like,
they don't deserve her pension.
Well fuck,
I think they do.
You know?
Yeah.
It's weird.
I guess it's just because we aren't forced,
we aren't forced to pay teachers more.
We aren't forced to pay cops more.
We are forced to pay pilots more,
so they just don't get paid more.
Well,
I mean,
they can't,
they,
there's,
they don't have enough bargaining power to step away from it.
Yeah.
I think that I'm not smart enough to like say exactly why it's happening.
I just know that it's definitely an abusive tactic by a corporation to keep
these people to,
to whatever.
Cause they can do it.
Yeah,
and they said they and they know they can do it and people can't really go
anywhere else.
Yeah.
If you told me that my ticket was going to be 20 bucks more or 50 bucks more,
whatever the fuck it was,
and you could pay the pilots a fair wage,
as long as it's not an unreasonable,
I would take that
easy.
Easy.
Yeah.
20 bucks.
You don't think all those people,
I'm just kidding everybody on the plane and pays 20 bucks,
but the baggage shit shit go like,
what's that?
What's that going for it?
That was,
I understood it at that when we're going through that gas problem that we're
having,
but now it's just ridiculous that they even charge for bags.
If you have three bags,
that shouldn't be a hundreds of dollars.
Why don't they just add that into the price?
You know?
Well if they're going to charge 50 bucks for a bag,
when it gets to everything in that bag should be folded nicely.
Maybe a little tree to put it in there with a thank you.
Did you see that
where the uh,
the opened up her bag and they found a vibrator in it and they wrote a note,
a little letter and said,
get your freak on.
Oh,
cool.
And now that's a lawsuit.
I'm sure they're going to fucking have the gun
killed.
What about that guy catches died?
I think it was American or continental airlines.
Lots of studies and they found it and it was so mountain nutrition.
Then the cat was like on life support and on Facebook it got thousands and
thousands and thousands of people backing it up.
And it just died this week.
The loss of for like a long time I lost,
it was hiding out in the uh,
whatever.
Like you went into the,
the have it a long time ago.
Yeah.
A couple of patches died two days ago.
Oh,
it happened a couple of weeks.
Penguin,
nobody seems to keep dragging the penguin.
Who didn't go to a,
where were supposed to go in New Zealand,
they were like raising them.
They kept releasing him.
But he kept coming back.
Whatever happened.
Yeah.
Like I mean,
not that they were tracking that bitch for a walk cause I was like,
you know,
if he comes back one more time they should really just fucking kill them.
Yeah,
I think so.
Cause he just doesn't want to be penguin.
He's wants to be a
whatever,
a parrot.
They found a buff up by the way.
They found a bunch of gay penguins in the zoo and a in Toronto.
And they're,
they're like people getting mad because they're separating the gay penguins and
put in the gay penguins and with the female penguins,
like separating them.
Oh that's not right.
And then people are mad,
they're like,
you know,
against gays.
And they're like,
no,
but we,
we've got a trick.
These,
these gay penguins in the fucking,
these girls,
otherwise like the species is going to probably die.
Like it's the first survival of the species.
I mean not,
you know,
it's survival of the zoo species.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
So what are they going to do?
Like I don't know.
There are African penguins and uh,
there,
uh,
I guess there's not that many of them.
I think I must be what they're saying.
And so they got gay.
Are they,
they,
you know,
they bang a chick just for a goof.
I mean that would be,
I think a lot of gay guys would do that.
A lot of gay guys,
girlfriends that they might get the freak on with every now and then.
I think that's cool.
Yeah.
I mean if,
you know,
I think it's probably way easier for a gay guy,
more Hawaiian coffee to do that.
No thanks.
I'm good.
I think it's probably way easier for a gang guy to do that.
You know,
the gay punk.
Um,
I was going to say the gay penguin thing I think is a good,
good thing cause I think they have every right to marry.
They should marry them and then they should watch for call it,
let them adopt.
It's kind of Douchey that they separate them.
Yeah.
I think that was the,
every 90% of every species that's ever existed has gone,
are we going to keep the penguins forever?
What if like we get to the future and the future,
you know that we all can communicate with each other with our minds and you
know,
we live in some place where energy is created.
Do you think about that shit a lot.
I do too.
All the time.
Do you think we're going to keep penguins?
They're just going to be shit all over the place.
Waddling around this supposed to die off as opposed to,
I love that show.
I'm not perfect.
You ever see that?
The jail like,
uh,
without people the earth without people and like what would happen?
Like all the stuff we've ever built,
like within years we'll turn into like,
there's like only like three things that'll survive.
Like the pyramids,
the Hoover Dam for awhile,
you know,
like something,
Star Dome and Birmingham,
Alabama,
some weird comedy club.
They'll be like a funny bone chain it.
But yeah,
I love that kind of Shit.
And,
uh,
I also think about like all the food we eat,
we're like choices that like people will like,
you know,
corn and you know,
they made corn the way it was.
It used to be wilder,
you know,
it'd be like fucking Indian Shit you put on your door for like that kind of
stuff.
That was like real food.
It wasn't just like,
Hey,
I'm weird.
You know,
watch out Wiccan,
crazy corn.
And there's like probably were seeds that like no longer exists that probably
had all the cures for cancer and all that kind of stuff.
But we'll never know now because like we,
we eat like 20 things,
you know.
And that's about it.
Well also we change things to make them more durable.
You ever have some heirloom tomatoes,
heirloom tomatoes or tomatoes at Umaine when those old seeds,
God damn,
they're fucking good dude.
It's incredible.
What do they with the tiny or they're big now.
They're big,
big fucking shoot,
you know,
regular size and big,
and some of them are even smaller,
even have heirloom cherry tomatoes,
but God damn,
that's when you realize that tomatoes are supposed to be a fruit.
Tomatoes are not supposed to be a vegetable.
It's become a vegetable because it's durable.
So we've sucked all the deliciousness out of it and it's this pale,
pinkish,
sloppy fucking thing that melts in your mouth when you bite into it.
That's not what those other,
the old tomatoes were like the ultimatums or like a kind of a weird fruit.
There was fucking delicious.
Yeah,
they're delicious,
man.
Wow.
I remember when I lived in New Jersey,
my grandfather used to grow tomatoes in his backyard and they were fucking
amazing.
You know?
And this is like probably the 1970s you know?
And these tomatoes were just ridiculous and we would eat slices these tomatoes
and we've never had tomatoes like that since then.
My Grandmother,
I had those and rhubarb and rhubarb and stuffy.
My,
like my kind of my sneaky dessert that I thought was delicious,
but now I look at,
tastes so sour into just raw,
I guess those big tomatoes that my grandfather grew.
You can't get those and put them in a truck.
They just,
they'll be useless in a day or two.
I got to check that out there.
They'll rot like way quicker,
you know,
they go bad quick.
The heirloom tomatoes go bad pretty quick.
I've never had,
I've got to try that out on their fucking delicious man.
Tell you eat meat,
right?
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
Like did something like a army and then like when you go like,
and I was like in Brazil or something like that and we hate stake down there.
I was like,
wow,
what the fuck is this?
This is like really tasty grass fed.
Yeah.
It's like,
it's like different than army,
but uh,
you know,
it's like I'm such a fat,
said God that I'll eat any meat.
I mean,
I liked it more,
but I still like,
you know,
like they know what the Mcdonald's in Brazil,
they know what the fuck they're doing.
The two husker Korea's,
did you ever eat one of those?
What did they go and they bring the meat on a stick.
Like they have a full body check and all that kind of place that those places
are amazing.
They,
they,
you know,
I went to one of those in,
one of the things in Brazil is they serve like Oregon's shit.
I went to those and they had like chicken hearts and all these different things
that you don't owe you.
How could you,
oh Gotcha.
Sounds good.
We'll try them.
Yeah,
I've never had that.
Oh my God.
They like sort of,
they put some sort of a glaze on it and they grill it,
you know,
everything,
the way they cook everything.
And the true Hoss Korea is,
they have these steaks and they stick them like in front of the fire and they
rotate.
It's basically sort of like a rotisserie thing going on and then they glaze it
with this.
I don't know what they're,
they're basting saucers.
I don't know what the fuck it is,
but it's damn delicious.
And when you go to Brazil and the Brazil ones,
they had a lot of organs and shit.
They had like livers and hearts and stuff like that.
Have you always ate like such crazy things?
Like you eat bone marrow,
you eat like they always get like liver and stuff.
Do you,
do you always,
have you always been like that or is that something you got into later?
No,
I've always been attracted to eating Oregon's harried lamb.
I had to man the other day and it tastes like eating farms in Oregon.
I love it.
I love lamb,
a lamb all the time.
I think meat and Oregon's and stuff like that.
It connects you to your assertion connects you to a,
your,
your roots as a predator.
Yeah.
It's a cheap way to do it cause you're,
you know,
you're not actually going out and getting it yourself,
but you get the,
uh,
the charge of it.
You know,
I'm with you on that energy you get from meat that you don't,
I don't believe you get from vegetables when people can debate me on this.
And I've tried to,
I've tried vegetarian diets before.
I have a,
I did a vegetarian diet for over a year when I was doing martial arts and I was
competing.
I tried to stay at a certain weight.
All right.
Yeah,
I didn't like the way I felt.
Didn't,
I felt like weaker.
I Dunno,
it made his power.
I mean,
it gives you the fucking power.
Some bad ass
out there,
don't get me wrong,
but,
um,
but I think they're doing it wrong.
I Dunno.
As I'm older now,
I,
it's like all the steaks and all that shit that I used to eat,
like Burger,
Burger,
Burger over,
and it was a club diet because it was like,
you know,
you're up late and was like three things to eat.
All that fat and grease is going to having a great time.
But now,
now that you're older,
now you're like,
you know you like go to Taco Bell,
let's say,
you know it's like a treat and like it blows your fucking body apart.
Yeah.
If you take some time off fucking fuck me or something.
I really just have that feeling after eating a whole pizza.
Oh it's in a whole year.
Really a hole.
I was using that as a,
as a thing to do my show.
Like we still wanting to do the post production that like I was like okay I
won't eat pizza or fries.
And those were like my big food groups and like,
you know I was like as a treat I was like waiting and waiting way.
So like pizza,
a pizza party or something.
Wow.
Isn't that lame?
No.
A smart guy ever.
It's like,
yeah,
it's like I can only fantasize about it,
you know,
cause pizzas.
So like especially like deep dish or whatever.
New York supposedly as good pizza,
but this way cooler pizza out there right now that the New York,
New York,
I love a slice,
you know,
but like there's places like Chicago I think has like fucking them.
Well that deep dish pizzas,
not like a real pizza casserole design.
Your pizza is delicious.
It's great when you get like a deep dish one with like,
I remember I got a deep dish seafood pizza with like the fake crab and like
scallops and clams and shit.
I was like,
okay,
how is this a pizza California casserole,
Goddamn casserole.
Delicious.
Yeah.
So whatever it's going to be,
it's probably going to be like,
oh man,
I can't wait.
Yeah,
there's surprise.
I think I have to give up forever now cause like they're like cigarettes,
you know,
there's so bad for you,
you don't realize it.
But you know when you,
when you eat healthy,
whenever I eat pretty healthy.
But every now and then I'll go off the deep,
but then you know,
Oh yeah,
you've got to keep moving.
It's still,
you feel it.
You feel the fries,
you feel the,
the fucking,
the breaded chicken sandwich from Jack in the box sliding down your intestines
so you feel it.
Do I have a question?
Um,
do you like this song?
Because this to me is a cheesy song,
but it's horrible.
But every time I listened to it,
I can't stop thinking if you like,
this is that song cause I work out.
I do know that
Jersey shore there as well.
Listen,
this,
I went from,
I don't,
I don't know.
I got my all,
I don't know any music that's playing today.
All Day.
All I listened to his like seventies I lifts in into,
this is what I listen to.
I listen to led Zeppelin,
I listen to Jimi Hendrix.
I listened to the almond brothers.
I listened to talk radio or listen to Dwight Yoakam lately.
That's it.
All right.
For this show,
I don't want to hear some new music for this show Thursday.
Don't play it for me.
And when you walk out
to do it,
your fuck up dairy,
I don't know.
I don't know any music,
man.
I,
I hear new music and I'm like,
what the fuck is this?
And so on and be like,
that's a huge hit.
And I'm like,
what are you talking about?
How's that possible?
Do you,
do you feel like it's like yourself when you're a kid of like,
my dad would always like,
I play nights,
you know,
he's like,
that shit is awful.
He was always screaming at me.
Luckily I don't get it.
I'm an old man.
What I became just like every other person's dad became just like when you were
a kid and your dad didn't get your shit,
you know,
damn well here's the cool thing about porn,
which is like everybody has that walk.
I'll walk up whatever porn thing.
And like I've been watching all these old tapes,
there was like some really like just hardcore fucking tunes in there,
if not like classical Vivaldi,
you know,
like they,
they really,
these movies were really more movie than they were sex.
And,
uh,
they would have like,
you know,
they'd have like ambient music and then they didn't have love themes and all of
a sudden like a sax solo would start playing as the girls coming get going down
on a dude.
So it's weird that like,
you know,
everybody has this image of the pouring of just like that Waka Waka are fucking
bullshit.
But that's like every comic's joke their first couple of years.
Yeah,
the chicken boom,
boom bang.
It's not,
it's not all like that.
It's,
I know it's weird.
Sort of a meme.
Yeah.
It must have been someone's joke and everyone else has just been sort of swiping
it.
I mean there's a lot of that in the form,
but then there's also like this weird,
you know,
just crazy,
like Gregorian chanting or something.
I was in like tons of the porn music cause I know like where is it from you,
I've got to make sure I have it right.
So when you're watching these you put them aside and go,
okay,
this one is interesting because of this.
And you're like,
mark it.
Yeah.
Well,
it really had to do with what we'd be doing the show of like who he get to be on
the show.
So you know,
a lot of these alleged ends having done porn in a while and they moved on to do
other things and like,
I'm sure there's a million people asking them to do shit.
So I didn't want to be a jerk off and just be like whatever.
So wait to see where we had access to do
the girls that were in the films and then they're here today.
Yeah.
And they'd be like a play by play kind of stuff.
And we asked them like,
it's not like a James Lipton accuracy,
it's a porn party.
It's just like this,
like serious like yeah,
you'd love to do it just hanging out.
But they have to be willing to like embrace their past.
Oh,
they're totally cool with it.
I mean,
I don't see why they wouldn't be because it's like you don't have any
resistance.
Like none of them say,
hey,
that's in the past.
Oh,
some of them don't want to do it.
They've moved on in their lives and we respect.
But uh,
you know the ones that do do it,
it's all celebration and tribute to their films.
Right.
And like Georgina Spelman,
who's the devil in Ms. Jones,
which is people always talking about the behind the green door is like the
ultimate della Ms. Jones is like a way cooler movie if you asked me,
cause it's got like a really interesting,
like a hell damnation kind of plot to,
it really came out the same year as the extra cyst or around that time.
And I played in movie theaters and it blew people away.
And it's a good movie.
Yeah,
I think it's a really good movie because it's about a woman who kills herself,
a Georgina spell have in place like a spinster woman who calls herself.
She's did not spoiler.
Oh,
okay.
Well we don't want them can watch the whole movie.
But at the end,
you know,
she goes to hell and she gets to sample all the pleasures of the flesh and the
devil in Ms. Jones Devil and Michelle and,
and Ms. Jones.
And I'm at the end,
you know,
what happens is she was a spinster who denied herself and she becomes like a
sex,
you know,
she's awakened sexually.
And,
uh,
the ending is a very cool twist ending for a porn movie or any movie,
which is like,
you know,
she has spend eternity with,
uh,
I assume it's a,
a priest or a man who doesn't like policy and she needs to be fucked.
So you would know.
It's very cool.
It was like before the x files was weird.
I'm trying to relate it to something you,
you would know this or um,
because,
uh,
you,
you're so deep into that world at what?
And when deep throat came out,
they thought that was going to be like the beginning of like legit movies where
they showed people fucking right.
Yeah.
D throw we never had access to because that's like a legendary film that like
everyone says they own and I need unreal license,
everything.
So everyone says,
well,
deep throat,
I can't,
I can't give you the exact company who distributes it,
but uh,
they deep throat is definitely one of the movies that everybody goes to.
Like Debbie does.
Dallas is another one where it's right.
You know,
it's really hard to like lock down the rights to use that kind of stuff.
And sure.
I had rights to use all the stuff that we use.
Debbie does.
Dallas just had a great name.
It wasn't the best port in the world.
It wasn't the best porn,
but it's still like that girl,
the girl who plays Debbie,
I forget her name right now.
She's super hot and like,
uh,
we had on,
this was like the pilot for the show.
I did was the greatest name of all time though.
Uh,
yeah,
like we,
we had on Robert Kerman who was the guy who bangs Debbie and Debbie does Dallas,
super cool guy lives in New York and like,
he was like one of these legends who were like,
I can't believe he's going to do the show.
You know,
we were like so excited.
And,
uh,
that was like for a different,
actually that was the pilot that we have never shown.
Does he not do porn anymore?
No,
he doesn't do it.
He's,
you know,
like,
uh,
I'm sure he would love to do it because like anything else,
you know,
that was his,
his scene.
But you know,
it was just cool to watch him watch himself in the porn movie and like you said,
you're right.
It wasn't that great.
It was like really tongue in cheek and like,
um,
Debbie,
whether she's alive,
dead or just doesn't want to be found,
I the song about her man,
she's like just super hot and like she's fluffing her lines and she's basically
laughing the whole way through the movie.
And you know,
just like at the end when you finally get to see your fuck,
you're like,
it was worth it.
You know what I'm saying is like,
it's like a nice pay off,
like the pin,
Yada,
broke lots of candy for everybody.
Good Times.
So you,
you a,
you can't use that one.
No,
I can't.
Like,
I,
I'd love to use this so many other ones.
So there's,
there's a few movies like that that are worth like a lot of money I guess.
Yeah,
no,
honestly,
yeah,
they're definitely collectors.
Is there a way that you could license it for probably down the road,
down the road and she'll give you doing a season two and season one successful I
hope.
Come on.
Who the fuck ever it is that owns Debbie.
Does Dallas don't be a whore with this.
Debbie does Dallas,
uh,
behind the green door and um,
you know,
uh,
they'll move back just talking about the delta.
Those are the ones that everyone kinda knows.
But then there's,
Joe,
you'll back me up on this hundreds and thousands of tapes that no one has ever
seen or like ultra flesh with sake is a great fucking movie.
I mean,
it's hilarious.
I watch it with Jim Norton and Sake and Jim knows porn better than me any day,
every day,
all day.
And like he was gay.
He was digging it and like it's got like crazy scenes in it.
It's a Scifi thing.
And e three the extra testicle,
which is one of the points parities,
Ron,
Jeremy actually wrote it and you know,
he took us through some of it and like unfortunately killing me,
watch clip by clip by clip.
We can't watch entire movies cause then we'd just like,
you know,
half an hour to half hour an hour man.
Oh God man,
you should do it like full on mystery science theater side where they do,
they do the whole movie and I wanted to make sure that it was different enough
from them because they're their thing with the robots where they're looking at
the movie,
we kind of like turn,
we're always facing the crowd.
Like we're different and we pop in and out and it's not like that scene where
like they used to have like really cool segments with Joel hot,
hot Hodges.
Right.
He would like have to run in with the puppets and watched the movie and then
they run out and do like some kind of crazy,
you know,
like sketch.
And I was like,
that really worked,
you know,
and I,
I want,
I didn't want to do any of that.
I just wanted to get to the heart of like what,
what I,
what I wanted to do,
which is like get comics talking and it's not about porn only.
It's a lot of justice,
like rail and each other.
And then bring them out the porn star to legitimize the show.
And I think just from the feedback we've got,
thank you so much to all the people who like this stuff,
the people who do it,
you know,
can't thank you enough.
And I'm hosting the Avian Porn awards this year and you know,
I've,
this is my second time and this time I'm letting them stick it in this time.
It's anal.
No,
this time we're going full tilt.
But uh,
it's like these people really do.
Honestly,
they're super cool and the fact that they let us even just like hang out with
them was,
was really cool.
So you've embraced her,
the porn comedy connection.
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
We're all loners were Ronan,
you know what I'm saying?
We were fucking warrior for road warrior.
I'm sort of a connection this fucking evil.
And that's what I think is like,
well we were talking about like jobs and security.
Like you and I both know that like we work week to week,
whether it's a,
you know,
like,
we've both done okay.
But you remember back in the day like wow,
if I don't get anything this month and I don't know what's going to happen.
Like one of those weird really wondering whether they should be doing this.
You're like,
you know what,
here,
can I sell that?
Uh,
yeah,
I sold all my comic books.
Did you darkest moment.
I'm like God,
Sola my comic books and still just terrible collector dude.
Like what,
what a deal.
How about coins?
I would find that it's like the weirdest collection.
No,
I've never collected it.
I clicked pool cues.
I play pool.
So I collect,
not on like when you were a kid,
fights like artwork,
you know,
it's like canned card.
Most of them were like made by,
you know,
master pool cue manufacturers.
You know,
when I was a kid,
like I collect the army men like I loved it but not like the really cool ones.
Just like cons of army men.
Right.
It's to set them up and have these amazing wars.
Like they do like jokes on it now.
Like the war of the couch pillow,
the pillow pillow.
People wouldn't let the what are in my own head
and they were all on like snowboards.
Yeah.
Just like slap,
set them down.
The fucking does amazing battles would be like all stuck to like one little
platform and you put them places.
Me and my friend used to do these battles where we would put army men on each
side of the kitchen and with a golf ball kind of like bowling where you'd roll
and trying to talk each other.
Yeah.
That's the shit people did before video games.
And what,
what,
what happened?
And it's like,
um,
every time like my parents would get thrown out of their house or something like
that,
you know,
like they move,
they go like,
okay,
we've got to throw stuff out.
What do you want to like the army man and I'll be like,
no,
hold on to that.
I think I know someone who wants that.
It's like that was like on one like treasure from the head to keep the army men.
They were crazy and it was like some were big,
some were tiny,
so I'd have to make up stories in my head of like how they would be,
whatever
that was in the marbles for awhile just to play marbles,
illegal toy and kids.
Now someone could swallow.
One kid might swallow it and ruined it for everybody else.
Yeah.
We played with marbles and Jack's Jackson just designed so you could slip on one
and it impales.
You're fucking skull.
Yeah.
Think about what that is.
Little metal spikes you're playing with.
You could throw those on the road and flatten so woods fucking car,
but that's a
little shurikens.
I mean think of Jack A.
Ball in Jackson.
You just set yourself up for a scenario where someone's going to step on that
fucking ball in,
in Pale.
Those Jackson or eyeballs.
My Mom's friend's kids,
they're like allergic to like candy or something,
but it's not like one of those like it's just like something that they like gum.
I don't think they're allowed to have gum.
Oh.
And I'm like,
wow,
like what?
What do you,
what do you want to hold the battery?
I'd be like,
yeah,
you know,
like we're kids.
Eventually.
I'm like,
oh,
I don't know what we can get you off the wind.
I don't,
I don't know.
I'm only going to be so safe.
Well I guess that's the problem with these kids,
you know,
whatever.
Nobody judge today.
D Do you ever look back at like,
you know when you,
when you first started out in comedy and you looked at all the years that you
put in now he think come,
what if I had to do that again?
Oh Shit.
I have to go through all the early part again.
I don't know if I could do with,
I don't know if I could actually do it because I,
back then I was so like I hated myself so much and I still hate myself,
but the heat,
the self hate propelled me forward cause where I was was a dark place.
So it kept propelling me forward.
It about comics and hating themselves.
You hate yourself?
No.
Yeah.
You don't know.
I think I hated myself when I was young.
Yeah.
No,
I,
I dunno.
It's just like,
hey,
did other people too.
How you doing now?
I really hated myself and I still hate myself and it's like,
it's such a great propeller of forward that though.
Will you try,
what is,
is the motivation to not hate yourself anymore?
To push toward my secret weapon.
I mean,
when you say that it propels you,
how does it propel you?
The self hate?
Does it propel you in that inspires you to not want to hate yourself more so you
know harder and kindness to propel you?
I don't know.
I feel like it
gives you like power of like,
you know,
just like you're an evil place and like whatever.
Like especially back in the early days with the heckling,
you know,
it was like they were fucking heckling me and I already hated myself.
So like it just fit
it,
made it feel right shit on yourself.
Whether it has,
yeah.
Like I just felt good.
It just felt like normal,
like verbally abusive fucking like homecoming,
you know?
So I don't know man.
I do.
You're a younger comics so you probably don't feel that way.
I don't have time to feel anything.
Right.
You go
bro.
Stay numb.
Yeah.
Well you got like the super hot girlfriend and that's great cause you're
emotionally like numb.
Right?
So she'd be like,
what are you thinking?
Nothing.
How many I've got left and how many loads are left?
It's like that movie about time.
How many loads are left.
Yeah.
It's an amazing number though.
How many comics just have something in the back of their head?
Either sort of self hate or just to an intense,
uh,
uncomfortable.
Yeah,
I'm kind of comfortable feeling about themselves.
And the world they live in and socially awkward.
There's a lot of those dudes,
you know,
the fact that like,
we lose all these really good guys like Geraldo,
Greg Giraldo,
and uh,
you know,
even before that,
uh,
you know,
Jerry Redd Wilson who was a guy from,
years,
years back,
he was not a self hate and guy who was like a party guy,
fun guy,
you know,
horrible experience.
A meningitis is what,
it wasn't drugs or anything like that,
but he was about to be engaged and everything.
And I was looking at guys like that who would like so full of life and I'm like,
Gee,
you know,
what the fuck am I doing?
You know,
this guy was like always had a smile on his face,
always.
You know,
he was so excited about like comedy and not being,
you know,
leaving his day job.
It's like I had day jobs and I was like,
you know,
I don't give a shit,
fuck,
I don't know what to say.
It's just really weird.
Um,
the experience.
So when you say,
can you do it again?
I don't know.
I don't know if I could ever do it.
Do it again.
I would think I'd like to do something cooler than comedy now.
Like locksmith thing or like something you know like something loan,
you know,
loan fucking
Gamer,
a gamer maybe or celebrity poker kind of do like you're like really good at
poker or something.
You know?
I wouldn't want to be some kind
of an artist.
Grades.
Yeah,
maybe a comic book artist or sculptor or something like that.
I'd want to do,
I mean I think it's all the same thing.
I think it's just putting your,
your,
your energy into something that you create and for us it just happens to be that
our personalities are fucked up enough that we want to being on stage.
I'm just lucky I don't want to be an actor cause that fucking like I feel bad
for them.
It's like everybody in this town grows up and then comes up with the whole
feeling of like I can be an actor and like you know,
everybody can be an actor but like being a really good one.
Like,
like a really good one is like fucking difficult.
And that's what that would be like.
Cause I know it's a good roles.
The good roles are very difficult.
I can only imagine because I could give a shit about like that kind of that
world,
you know,
it's not my world,
but like being a really good comic is important to me.
So I assume it's the same thing for acting,
you know,
for the real actors.
But the amount of shit,
like you said,
roles that they have to do.
Shucks.
You know,
and they can only be as good as what they're asked to do.
The hardest comedy,
you can do whatever you want,
you know?
So the hardest part about sitcoms is finding good writers.
Really fucking for sure.
You know,
I had a couple of development deals after news radio and I was super spoiled
because I went from a show where Paul Simms is amazing,
brilliant fucking guy.
I mean he just had a sense of comedy.
He knew how to do it.
He's an amazing,
you know,
he just,
he had a sense of creating characters and the whole,
the ending.
But you go from that to some of the shit that people are slinging out there and
you're like,
well,
if you're an actor and this is all that's available to you,
you find yourself on some shitty fucking show slang in some canned comments.
You know,
like some two and a half men type shit.
Like I watched one of the one episode of that show,
or Charlie sheen was on a couch with some key,
the little fat kid and they're,
they're going back and forth.
And I'm like,
wow.
And I was imagining myself,
what if I had a fucking say this?
What if I had to do,
even if I had to do it for 2 million bucks a week,
I mean,
I'd fucking do it.
Don't get me wrong.
What if I had to do that?
And I was like,
I'd probably go crazy too.
I'd probably go on a nutty coke bench.
Yeah.
He,
he said there was
redundant.
Yeah.
But he still honestly,
yeah,
I thought that everybody's like,
you know,
one show was better than the other and there was some really great shows,
but I could give a shit.
I know it's all set up punchline the punchline,
whether it's really well disguised or not watching to see what it is.
If they were smart,
they'd let you help.
Yeah.
There's a lot of people that don't want you to help.
They don't want you to be afraid of you because you're going to want you to ad
Lib.
I yeah,
we had that on news radio the last season when every season,
but the last season we had a new producer in the last season and they just sort
of like cut down,
lay on the ad libs.
What it used to be is we would take a scene and Dave Foley would like go over it
and we'd find out like what was kind of,
what was,
what wasn't working and what didn't feel right,
what you know and fully was always creating new lines and creating new things
and you know,
here's like a sort of a secret producer of the show and you sort of cut out.
He's a cool dude,
great guy,
genius,
brilliant,
brilliant comic actor.
The
kids in the hall like,
Ah,
I don't want to turn this into like a big comedy stroked out,
but that that's,
that's an underrated ope sketch show.
Amazingly,
I think
that's probably one of the best I've ever seen personally,
and I never was really a sketch comedy guy,
but I love that show.
I was really sketch comedy guy either.
I've always said that it's like,
I'll laugh three times for not laughing seven.
It's not a good ratio,
you know what I mean?
It's like three out of seven gigs or gags on.
Those things are good.
Yes,
absolutely.
Whatever.
These sketches go on and on.
If you can find it strong ending,
you're there.
You know?
If he asked me,
you could smoke if you want.
I'll turn on the air thing.
Oh,
I don't want to,
I don't want to go.
I see he's got the new laptop because I'm in the process of buying some new
computer.
Think that's an admission.
Oh,
is it?
See that's how far behind I am.
This is a newer one.
What does that,
Gee,
what is it?
A Mac book pro 17 inch one.
I don't know if I can travel with that now.
You're like a Douche.
If you travel with that theater.
He and I've taken it out and put it in that little,
are you really a Douche if you do that?
I don't know like everybody else down,
you know he's gotta to have like a droid,
aren't they do old style or your phone?
Your phone is ridiculous.
Hey,
easy.
Trawlers don't gang up on the old man colors.
What time is it?
Uh,
it is four 49.
Okay.
I had a question now is insomnia.
You guys released,
you didn't release it on the Act insomniac?
I'm sorry.
They went in some you guys released like the best of insomnia but you never
released every single episode right?
On DVD or blu ray or anything like that.
Um,
that's up to the comedy central people cause they own the shell.
But I assume that they did release,
I know that there was a season two and then they'd never released the next
season.
And people ask me that all the time and I'm like,
I wish,
but I assume it's all on Netflix now.
So that sound the background,
ladies and gentlemen here,
that horrible noise.
That's cause I'm smiling cause cause David tells smoking.
I'm sorry guys.
I know I knew you needed it.
I looked at you and go like an hour.
I saw it in your face.
It's okay.
Everybody.
You're never smoked cigarettes?
No,
I tried it once when I was 15 I tried it.
My sister smoked and I smoked weed with some friends and she wound up being a
smoker from that day on.
Oh yeah,
sister smoked since she was 14 holy shit.
I think she's quit now.
Pretty sure she quit a while ago.
But God,
there's no way you could smoke and do a martial law.
No,
no,
you couldn't.
No Way.
Cause you know I did Jujitsu for like a couple of years where I'm on long
island,
you know,
and I was horrible at it and it was like really?
But I really do wish that it's like one of my big regrets is that like I really
wished that I had stuck with it because I think that's the coolest thing.
And that would have kept me off the booze and the smoking.
It really wouldn't really well tend to focus on it.
And the most important thing,
it calms you down.
It's so,
so bad.
Maybe a little too loud.
I'm going to turn this thing down.
I know.
I can hear people complaining on Twitter already.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry dude.
I'll put out a cigarette in a minute.
You've met that the host of a pawn stars,
it says on your Wikipedia like seven years before they actually had to show off.
He was working on the show as he was working on my show.
But uh,
that is a cool place in Vegas.
The porn.
The porn star people.
Yeah.
Well you can't quit those things,
Huh?
Now I gotta quit.
I mean,
I don't want,
do you have to,
because I'm now I'm like really old and like I,
I,
she could go wrong.
Well,
I'm sure shit is already wrong,
but it's really more about like,
I've run out of reasons not to,
not to not quit.
Like,
you know,
I'm always like,
well,
I'm doing this on after I do a special or whatever,
I'll to it.
But it's like there's always some excuse and all my friends have quit now and
they're doing the electronic cigarettes or they're just,
you know,
just fucking,
I dunno,
white knuckling it.
Does it help you right?
No,
no.
What it really does help me do is kill the fucking many hours.
A fucking downtime of like in between shit like radio or like outside of an
airport.
Like just waiting for my flight.
Just smoking is like something to do.
I never really get off on like hitting the gift shop or like seeing what new
good stores.
I haven't these fucking airport mall.
So I was like,
smoking is cool,
you know.
And then there's some airports where they only let you smoke outside,
which I think is ridiculous since that cigarette paid for that airport.
Motherfucker,
you go taxes.
Do you,
um,
when you go on the road,
do you bring people with you and do you go on the road by yourself?
Man,
I used to bring all these really cool dudes with me and I'll just yell at some
names.
Jay.
Oh cause saying Mike,
Vicki [inaudible] Kurt,
Kurt Metzger a monster.
Yeah,
Curtis Super.
Now what that dude up in Montreal,
he's a great comic comics.
Very funny guy.
And uh,
you know,
these guys were like,
uh,
they were,
they were already,
I thought they were like headline and material,
but they wrote like earning their bones and they were dirty like me and like
Yoshi comes out with me something.
But now like we can't afford fly.
But my,
my opener for years and years was showing rouse and Doug Stanhope used to Sean.
Sean is sick right now.
He's got rheumatoid arthritis,
but he's one of the filthiest,
dirtiest smartest comics I've ever fucking like his jokes just in my head.
Like sometimes they just ricochet around and like,
you know,
he's just got to get out there more and do stand up.
That's what I think we're right in.
He's not feeling too good.
So yeah,
his health is kind of jacked.
That's like makes an ash tray in the flesh.
How many do you smoke in those day?
About two packs.
So that's why.
So we had done like an hour and you already started to shake and he's trying,
you reach into your pockets.
Predatory.
I really will find your a,
this is actually him smoking made me feel good though.
Yeah,
but just smelling it made me feel.
Have you,
uh,
how many of you cut yourself down to I'm a pack a day now.
Why is these filters now too?
Which is cool.
You can.
So where do you get that?
I still don't know.
They're made in China.
So you know,
they're right.
You get to see what's going into your lungs.
God,
why did I do that?
Oh,
I want another one.
Something that you could substitute it with the gum.
You went to the grossest thing sometime if you really went gross out,
you probably Dennis million times,
but you take a hit of a cigarette and then you blow it through a paper towel and
then you look at what,
it's just a black mark from the paper towel.
So bad
for you man.
Might meanwhile small joints all day sun.
Yeah.
But that's not,
that's not the same thing,
right?
It actually opens up your lungs.
It's good for people that have asthma.
I said,
yeah,
my favorite asthma,
it's mostly marijuana is good for that.
It's good.
Uh,
it's supposedly dilates your something in your lungs
and it's also like,
it also has something else that's really good.
Like there's something else,
like
there's tons of shit that's good.
Cannabinoids,
all the different stuff that the way it affects your brain.
Supposedly it's supposed to a retard the growth of tumors and even shrink them.
Oh Wow.
There's a lot of amazing things.
Your body is all,
most people's body,
you know,
like when you're,
your body goes wrong.
It's because of malnutrition.
It's cause of poor genetics,
which cause of stress intention.
And if you could take any of those,
I have a mix.
Things are going to be better.
And the best way to take off stress intention is weed.
It's a great way to take it off.
You hit that and just everything just kind of comes into perspective.
You're there.
I'm going to be okay.
It's going to,
you're going to be fine.
You'll,
you relax significantly or you overthinking.
If you go too deep in the rabbit hole,
well you gotta become a,
you gotta learn how to ride the waves.
You know,
like nobody's good at surfing the first time on the water.
You Fall,
you fucking hate your head.
It's like,
it's an uncomfortable balanced thing.
You got to learn how to surf correctly.
When you watch those guys and they're fucking getting on a 50 foot wave there in
the tube that they didn't learn that yesterday.
That shit takes a long time to master surfing.
Marijuana is just,
it's very similar.
You have to learn how to regulate the experience.
You got to learn how to just go with the high.
Right.
I loved it.
The other day you were at the Ice House and somebody was talking to you and
you're like,
I can't talk right now.
I just got,
I'm to stone.
You said something about like driving really fast and that your car freak you
out.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Driving really fast.
Um,
I was just,
uh,
I was just thinking when we got there,
we smoked some pot.
I was just thinking how stupid am I driving around in a convertible?
What if this thing flips cause nothing above your head.
Like what the,
what am I retarded?
I seen flip cars before.
I'm like why do I have a card?
It doesn't have a roof.
What?
Cause I liked the top down and the wind in my hand.
Well what am I doing?
What am I retarded?
It's still a safe move.
It's cool.
It is cool.
You know
I was,
I'm sorry I was just gonna say like pod is so prevalent in La and like
everywhere else in the country like it's hard to get,
it's hard to get.
I remember one time,
I was like years ago I was walking down sunset and you know how like there's
always traffic there.
So like there's like a light and like,
you know I was waiting to cross and this kid and like some shitty car that you
only see like in movies,
like some kind of like Datsun,
fucking Hugo,
whatever,
all beaten up.
Mangled.
He pulls out a bong and he's time in the light.
I saw that.
I was like,
you see that in every,
like Harold and Kumar knock off movie.
But I was like,
I really saw it in real life and I was like,
wow,
this is la.
You know what he's like puts it back down and he's driving off to his fucking
whatever music or it's a very strange
book.
It's an old man with a pipe.
The other day I had a red light and he was just like an old man,
just lighting a Piko at a red light.
Wow.
Classic.
Well that's why these guys,
them joints of their role and today with those cigarette machines are perfect
because it looks like a cigarette.
Yeah,
like a joint over a pipe.
Yeah.
I don't think you should keep lighting things when you like them.
You're supposed to use like a hemp WIC because then you're just dealing with
only in the fire and some organic material in the Hamp,
but when you're lighting it with a lighter man,
you're dealing with lighter fluid,
like you can taste it on the pipe.
I don't like that taste.
I think that's bad for your joints.
I light it at the tip and the smoke,
the whole thing.
And you're good joints all day.
Joy to the way to go or a vaporizer.
They sent me this new vaporizer but I haven't figured out how to do it yet.
So when you go to like Amsterdam you'd been there?
I'm sure.
Never,
never,
never.
When I go to Europe
it's only for the UFC.
And you know I have kids so when I go to Europe I just don't,
I want to be there.
It's small time as possible and then shoot back over.
So when I'm over there for the UFC I don't have the time to go an extra day.
It's an extra day.
I don't see my kid so I always fly
back home.
Well maybe one day you take a vacation,
you go over there with the kids and stuff like that.
I don't know if they still do it but like the pot there,
you know,
cause we all smoked pot,
cause it's free.
And they also had hash and I think mushrooms at the time.
So like you can go on and do like all these crazy things in this little area.
But then once you walk out on the street,
like Tom Rhodes,
who's great comic,
you know,
he lived there for a long,
long host of a show there,
right?
Yeah.
He was hosting a talk show,
which I think he,
you know,
everybody's like,
you should write a book.
I'm like,
once Tom Roads going to write a fucking book because that guy has some fucking
amazing experiences.
Sure.
He's like one of my favorites.
And he also is like a great joke writer.
Great Dude is a great deal.
Really Nice cat.
His Dad was a Vietnam helicopter pilot and he recently passed away and that was
like a big loss for all of us because I was always like asking him questions
about that shit.
And I was like,
you know,
tell me more shit about your dad because that was really cool.
As brother special forces,
uh,
like Greenbury dude.
So talk about the different roads in life.
You don't want guys like,
uh,
you know,
comic fucking pothead fucking great dude.
And the other guys,
uh,
you know,
contract fucking killer elite dude.
You know,
it was really,
I was like,
that's the Sitcom I want to see.
You know.
How was your day?
A mercenary.
Yeah.
But Tom is like,
you know,
he should write a fucking book man.
Cause he's like been places like Vietnam and all those different places.
He probably knows where to get weed anywhere,
I'm sure.
Right?
Yeah,
he's an explorer.
You got Nina Hartley coming on your show and Bill Burr.
I just,
I was talking to somebody the other day,
she's thinking about getting into comedy and doing comedy.
She is,
yeah.
I was going to have her on a future desk squad show you.
How long has she been doing comedy?
I,
and I think she's just about to start.
I think she's doing her first set that night.
Thursday at Bria impro.
Oh Wow.
I think,
I'm not sure,
but uh,
she didn't go on stage a few times.
It would just be,
it'd be like,
it'd be like a,
see what happens
when people pay to see those shows and I'm sure she's going to do fine.
But you know,
I,
I have a very strong,
no opinion
on people who have just started doing comedy,
getting on stage in front of
[inaudible].
That's always the big thing.
When you did it,
you had already done it in the past a bunch and Brian took a long time off.
Once went up,
he took like fucking eight years or seven years.
I could never do that.
And then he went up in front of a UFC crowd.
This is his first time doing standup in seven years.
He went up in front of a sold out crowd in Atlanta.
Yeah,
we three the wolves,
dude,
you went up in a midnight show and everybody was Hammad show Friday.
Yeah,
sold out midnight show Friday.
That was his first time on stage at seven years have been brutal.
He pulled the head some good.
He had some good jokes.
I want to do it.
What of these shows,
Joe?
I don't give a time Thursday.
I fucking love your crowd.
My crowd loves you.
I,
anything you want to do is show up Thursday.
If you in town at the Pasadena Ice House.
Oh Fuck No.
I'm a guy.
I met the,
where am I in Phoenix?
A big place.
Comedy shows stand up,
live,
standup live Friday,
Saturday.
I got just a new place,
right?
Yeah.
That place is huge and that's
huge for UFC.
A lot of two camps.
They're too big and there's somebody that just did it and he's like,
dude,
that is the best club ever.
That not only is the club amazing and huge,
but they also put you up and they're like the nicest hotel ever.
Sweet.
Like a human.
They're killing that Tempe Improv.
If that's the case,
the Tempe Improv was it,
that was a great club and rake club,
right?
I mean,
unless the town can support that many people,
which I guess it can,
if you have two completely different guys,
if you have like,
you know,
a one show you have like an urban guy and another show you have like,
you know someone else,
I'm like bill burr or something like that.
I bet you could fill to comedy clubs up,
but it's gotta be hard.
One's a four 50 and one's a 600 they'll be able to fill it.
I'm like,
I can't do it.
You know,
it's like hundreds,
a lot of people and like,
you know,
it's like almost a theater.
That's where we talked about how active are you with the social media?
I hate it but that's the,
I do it.
But you know the point of it is like your crowd like it,
I always like hear that like you would just add the town or you're coming to
town.
I was like,
you know it's like Joe,
like you know you were mysterious dude.
Like I know you like,
like the fact that you found these people and they found you is great.
And like I would just like to fucking perform in front of all wild crowd.
Like,
cause I feel like the wild crowd is like the dying,
you know,
it's like everyone's on the reservation now.
This few people still out there fighting the good fights up.
Your crowd is wild and I want to like fucking,
you know,
well you know you are there people.
I hope so.
I mean for fucking free man.
I swear they love crazy fucking night.
Any shows you're ever doing,
let me know and I'll tweet it and retweet it and,
and people will come,
man.
No,
I just want to see you in front of you.
Yeah.
Your crowd and like,
I just want to see how fucking while that is because I know you like will not
stop.
You're like relentless.
You'll take it and take it and take it.
So you know,
it's cool when you have an audience that will also,
you know,
go along on the ride with you.
Otherwise,
yeah,
we'll need to know what you're doing.
Fucking rambling.
You know,
that's what I sometimes feel like I'm just rambling.
Do you find that most of the people that come to see you,
most of them are
big fans.
Most of them know all your shit.
They know me from TV but they don't really know my acts.
And whenever it got comes up to me with a CD goes like,
you know,
I listened to this,
this is like really important.
Like my dad and I were truckers and we used to listen to this story.
I love those.
That's like,
you're like,
wow,
there really are comedy fans.
And some of them like me and I'm like,
wow,
here I am feeling like a Douche bag hating myself.
You know?
I was like this guy,
you know,
said hey listen to this.
When I was in Iraq and me and my buddies,
you know,
we kept quoting lines and it really helped us kill the time.
That makes you feel good.
Like you're doing something.
But I'd see most of the people come out because either they like so you TV show,
which is good or that they want to just do something and then you heard your
name and then like when they tighten up on me,
then I fucking take it to the evil place and then comedy fans are with me.
But then the other people like we're not going to go that far.
You know?
I was like,
oh,
hold on.
Just guys.
You know,
that's like five midget jokes on her own will.
There's always going to be people that don't want to go there with you.
I respect it,
but I still got to do it.
Right.
Well,
I fuck it.
That's who I am
talking about this.
Um,
when,
uh,
it came up with a Dick Tracy Morgan thing came up.
Oh right.
And I was like,
you know,
that's,
uh,
that's a type of art form the going deeper than he's supposed to go through.
Really fucked up jokes that I like that.
I know it's not sincere.
These aren't sincere thoughts.
These are the days are ridiculous.
Rambling all over the top.
Ramblings exaggerations comedy and much like auto and George talked about auto
and George and you know,
and the Tracy Morgan thing where,
you know,
he went around saying that if his son was dead or if someone was gay,
would stab that little faggot.
Right.
Well look,
he didn't really mean that stop,
but he didn't really,
that was an hour.
Yeah.
He's just going,
he's saying the most ridiculous shit you can say.
It's not like a statement in front of a fucking jury.
You know what I mean?
It's not like a he,
he wrote this down,
this is doctrine.
This is how I feel about these people.
I mean I see both sides,
but you're absolutely right.
Absolutely.
See both got to everybody's got it right.
Be
Right there and people have a right to be pissed off about it.
But that's where it should end cause it is a comedy club and if anything he
should go like,
you know what,
if I'm going to say something that fucking explosive and whatever,
it better be funny.
And that's my whole thing.
It's like say whatever you're going to say but make it as funny as fucking
possible.
Otherwise these people do have a point where you just either like being hateful
or you know,
you're just being abusive and I get it.
But like a lot of it is exploring the fucking like how far are these?
Are you going to do it?
And there is like a,
there was like a self fucking jerking off to that.
You know,
I was like,
I'm going to say Stan hope is the ultimate guy.
Like,
you know,
he will take it to the point where you're like,
either you're fucking uncomfortable with how you're laughing at this
uncomfortable fucking moment of his is sick fucking twisted life or you're,
you're just like,
you know,
I cannot believe this guy is saying that.
And he shocks even me and I felt like I was unshockable so,
well,
he's another one who hates himself.
I know,
but he's,
he's,
he's perfect.
Brilliant.
He's perfect.
I think he's just,
he's one of my favorite human beings from one of the favorite people that I've
ever met.
That's a good way to
get to the point was I just fucking sad every fucking thing.
And there's nothing to fucking say.
It's like,
what am I doing?
Am I repeating myself?
And then we'll go up and crush about open,
just find some new angle for some new idea.
And he's,
he,
like you said,
he's out there really doing it for reals.
Told me like,
you know,
like we're more like,
I would check jokes like,
you know,
I was like look fanatical checking.
Like make sure like you know,
nobody's doing this or like,
have you heard something like that?
And like with stand up I'd always call him up and I'd be like,
do you have like a,
you know,
like you're saying like you have a bit worried that you might have her check do
that,
check with your buddies and see if they have an,
and you know,
you try and like at least figure out that like,
you know,
it seems weird,
right?
Yeah.
If it fits to purpose.
Like why do I knew it felt like a harness.
You can't remember if you have,
it gets blurry and it bothers you too.
Like when you're like,
you know,
I hope I didn't hear this cause I don't want to,
Jack actually bothers me because all the people talking shit about people that
have stole jokes and like,
you know,
there's a lot of,
there's a lot of gray area in the whole like whose bed is it?
But like when you hear it like word for word?
Yeah.
It's basically just when you know a guy,
like there's a few guys where you know that the only bits that they have,
they're any good or the similar bids to other people's rights.
And then they have other bits that aren't like anybody else's bits and they're
fucking terrible.
You know,
the,
and that's when you can really tell.
Well,
I just know that like the,
what I would call Stan hope.
And I go like,
do you have anything like a Unicorn's fucking,
you know,
grape soda.
And then he'd be like,
what?
He's like,
nobody thinks that way.
And I,
and I don't do jokes anymore,
man.
I don't know when I do look there,
and it's true,
he's like jazz.
He just goes up there and just starts fucking doing these thoughts.
They love him in England.
And that usually is a sign that they're pretty purist.
What the comedy over,
they're great over there.
I only do it every now and then,
but I just did Birmingham,
uh,
did,
this past weekend is fucking amazing man.
He's the nicest,
most polite crowd ever.
Sometimes that's not good when they're too polite.
I don't like that.
I agree.
But there were brightening one guy sorta kinda heckled but it just sort of
yelled at.
It was actually fun.
I don't like when they just sit there and upload it,
but I don't like over the top craziness.
Yeah.
Unless I can fucking partake.
Well I think this crowd was a little self conscious cause it's like I said,
I could see them all.
They were all lit up.
See I don't like that either.
I don't like to,
I like a dark.
I think the crowd needs to be in dark.
Just feel.
What do you like?
Do you like a small place?
Like if you had like 200 seats is your favorite or loves?
I love clubs,
theaters,
specials in theaters.
I'm not a theater act.
I have no big fucking point to my act.
Nobody wants you to do a special on a club,
right?
You have a job.
We're going to do when I'm in a club and the next one I do,
I promise myself I'm doing it in a club and that's a definite,
but I've done them in theaters and like,
it really makes you feel like,
you know,
wow,
I made so many mistakes and comedy and this is one of them.
Like I'm not a theater act.
I'll never be a theater act.
I'm a Dick joke.
Fucking late night comics.
And I'm like,
you know,
I'm proud of it now.
It's like I,
yeah,
that's what I want to be and you know,
kind of comedy.
My opinion,
it's just like who I am.
So funny,
silly comedy,
you know,
it's the,
it's the real shit,
you know,
it's the best stuff.
But there's some great theater acts.
I mean,
yeah.
Louis Louis Black and Mitch Hedberg.
I told him what those two guys,
both of them I thought were like very theater friendly.
Very like they worked really good in a big room.
Yeah.
Louis,
well Hedberg was great in a small room too,
man.
The weirdest acts ever.
Man.
Crazy following to man his,
his people.
Wow.
They were like,
this was before all,
all the media.
Yeah.
They figured out how to get in touch with each other and then that with these
kids,
man,
he would have been fucking huge if he stayed alive.
Imagine the jokes that he would have had,
you know,
like,
cause he was,
he was probably the most prolific I ever met.
Yeah.
In terms of clean comedy too.
He never had to go that thing like,
oh,
I'm doing Letterman.
I can ever take out the fucking,
the shit.
It's like he's always clean,
you know.
He had,
fuck,
it was rare.
He had like one fuck every 15 minutes or something.
And he was always,
he didn't need it because,
fuck man,
that's who he was.
Yeah.
He would have broke Twitter.
Oh yeah.
No one would have been able to fuck with him.
Twitter was written for,
the jokes are so tweetable.
Someone said,
do you want a frozen banana?
I said,
no,
but I want a regular banana later.
So yes.
It's like his style was so weird,
man.
And then there was a bunch of dudes who started sounding like,
a lot of people sound like there's a lot tell babies out there too.
But a lot of guys,
hey,
where'd you out when you hear somebody's up there doing you,
cause I know you've seen it.
Yeah,
yeah,
I see it.
But I,
you know,
I'm,
I'm so
joke,
like I'm like a joke or like it's really all about jokes that like if they're
going to do the cadence,
I'll do it with different cadence cause I can,
no,
your cadence is your,
whatever you fuck you want it to be,
you know,
you could change it.
Yeah.
Just what you have confidence in.
Right?
Yeah.
It's really,
it's really about like the joke,
like if they're doing like my cadence where the joke that's kind of like mine,
then I'm like,
dude,
you know,
wait til the next week when I'm not here.
Do you ever find yourself when you were young,
when you first started out sounding like someone?
Oh,
absolutely.
Uh,
Alan Hevian,
Collin Quinn were the two big influences.
And Richard,
Jenny,
the man,
I forgot Richard.
Jenny who no longer is with.
There's also another,
he was [inaudible],
I was at the comedy connection in Boston,
a little one when it was like a 115 seat room.
That's crazy.
Yeah,
and I sounded like I heard the punchline like I'm like,
wow,
okay now that like crossed the line.
Sounds like him.
You know,
I did a bill Burroughs podcast and we'll be talking about Richard,
Jenny and like running a couple of other podcasts,
but I think you're the only guy who really does get that.
Like he really was a huge influential,
he was the biggest touring act for a while.
I think in comedy,
like there was like dice and then Sam Kinison all those people,
but then like late,
he didn't get the credit he deserved for whatever reason.
Yeah.
Like in the late eighties and nineties it really was Richard Jenny's moment and
he got the ace awards,
which is like the cable.
He was doing theaters in show.
Absolutely.
No,
he was always on deck for a Sitcom,
you know,
like this.
It was going to be did one member.
Platypus.
Man.
Yeah.
I don't know what that was all about,
but he was,
his thing was,
look man,
they were always trying to plug them into something else who was in the mask
with Kerry and he wanted to be an actor.
He wanted to be famous.
I understand he wanted to be famous,
but he was a brilliant fucking comedian.
It's really,
it was our unfortunate that,
you know,
people don't appreciate how good he was when he was in his prime.
You know when we,
when I saw him in the late eighties I saw him,
I paid to see him.
I think I hadn't done comedy yet or maybe I had done like one open mic and I saw
him do an hour and a half at catch a rising star.
I saw him like three times and he did different hours all three times.
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
Completely different.
And all of it solid as a rock.
No,
no bad material and one punch line after the other punch line.
What I learned from that night,
yeah.
I learned from that guy how to cover the most ground that you can in a bit.
Bingo.
He beat a subject to the point where I'm at,
I'm like a chess player,
which makes you disappointed when you see a young comic that like starts a
little bonfire,
starts an idea,
then abandons it and goes to a completely different stuff,
different kinds of file and you can't,
you can't get a rhythm with them.
But with Richard,
Jenny,
he would,
whatever the subject was someone trying to sell him a car,
he would go into this thing and take you on a fucking journey and every bit was
like a five minute bit and because of that it was just like you would date take
you deeper and deeper and you really like appreciated the way he like looked at
things.
You know you got sucked into his sense of humor.
That's so fucking,
you know,
I'm glad you said that because I always say this to like the younger comics,
they were like,
who did,
how did you learn how to like tag a joke and all that?
Something like Richard Jannie was the guy that choked it up.
Milk a premise and even though a lot of this stuff now is hackney just because
it's been done a million times of like,
you know,
the dating,
like going through the French restaurant and whatever,
like all that stuff has been done over and over and over.
But when he was doing it,
it was,
it was basically really well written,
well crafted new material.
It's all,
it's like any joke,
you know,
it gets a little stale but they're always like this that sparked to it and yeah,
you're exactly right where he would just fucking take a topic.
He would not let go of it until he milked every possible fucking angle out of
it.
And I was like,
wow,
that's how you headline we'd materials and I never could,
I never could reach is like,
cause he would act out the two.
And I never had that kind of competence,
like both parts and the thing.
And he would occasionally play in birth parts and stuff.
He would occasionally,
um,
like uh,
go over a subject that you had heard people go over before.
Like,
you know,
he would do a bit like a,
about what you remember.
Everybody had a bit about when I was your age.
We had to walk 10 miles through the snow.
A lot of guys had those.
It was uphill both ways.
A lot of guys have those types of jokes.
A lot of comedians did and he did too.
So he had a subject that he knew had been covered,
but he covered it's so fucking,
well it's like he was as some master joke writer,
he knew how to
like really get the most angles out of a a premise and he wasn't,
you know,
he wasn't trying to be a some obscure hipster sort of weird reference or
anything.
Yeah,
it was just,
he was just a really prolific comic.
He was just,
he considered himself a real comic.
He was the act that you would take your mom and your buddy,
hey buddy too.
And you'd be like,
wow,
that could be like below blew.
Blew me away.
And when everybody says like he did a whole new hour,
it's like people love to say you're absolutely right.
He could do like five hours of different materials,
just like,
you know,
he was built for Vegas and like just headlining and like not many guys can like
crush in both places.
Like either you're crushing Vegas or you crushed like in like Shitty,
you know,
all over the country and like,
he was like bill for both and the heel is great power in theaters.
He was,
um,
he was a monster in the,
like I said,
in the late eighties when I went to see him,
he was one of the best comics alive,
but he was not a Boston guy though.
He was from Brooklyn and a B started at pips.
Right.
Pipsy that's right.
And I think when he,
like if you're in New York act,
then you went up to Boston,
like you would get your,
you get schooled because like they want you up though.
They would set you up to like,
I had to follow Steve Sweeney one time,
like with my 39 minutes of material and they do it at the verbal lounge and
they,
yeah.
And he would go up there and just do like five impressions that the place would
Florida all Boston centric.
Absolutely.
But you know what it was,
it was a good fucking school.
And then,
cause I wasn't cocky or anything like that,
but I never had to fuck to,
to face the home team the way I did in Boston.
And you really do face the home to you if you bomb and Boston,
you fucking,
you're not the legend that was,
that was,
that was a righteous,
a fucking bomb.
They used to do that to people.
They used to set people up.
I saw them set a lot of people up at the Nick's comedy stop.
They would have like literally Sweeney Gavin.
Kevin Knox had lost three guys who are just destroying,
I mean,
20 minutes of Samurai Sword Comedy where they've folded that steel over and over
again.
They've been,
those guys didn't do HBO specials.
So they were doing the same material for years and they,
it was a real problem because they kept,
like,
especially some of them,
uh,
you know,
you'd go see,
see him 10 years later and they had virtually the same act.
It became stale.
The town was too good to them and made them like,
the point of the whole thing is like,
you've got to move to the next level.
And it was too good.
They're making too much money
and something happened.
The new ones here,
it wasn't nearly as good as the old material and they just weren't the same gun
that they used to be.
But they were monster rocks too.
But when it,
when,
when these guys would,
when we're sending people up in the late eighties,
they were perfect.
They were just destruction machines.
But I saw a bunch of people get through A.
Dot.
My rare,
I got through it,
fine.
Dom Irrera went up there and that was,
yeah,
he was loved.
Um,
Thompson,
Larry,
he's a great guy too.
And back in the day,
like in the late eighties,
he was one of the top guys for short and he still is,
but I mean he was,
he was killing him back then and he went up after all those guys,
they set them up.
Gavin Sweeney just crushed Lenny Clarke meant it might've been letting one,
one of the nights
guys.
I,
I would,
I would fucking die a million deaths trying to follow those guys in Boston.
It's fucking hard.
They would,
they would,
they were like polished like you said and,
and like they just knew how to work that crowd.
Yeah.
But like,
uh,
like shemot another guy who I looked,
I looked up to starting out like he was a joke dude and then dark dude and like
his life backed up that darkness.
But like he was another guy where you talking about like material,
it's like every time I saw him he had a new bit about a new horrible thing that
happened to him.
Cams or wife or something like that.
Yeah.
And it's like,
you know,
everybody's like,
talk about your life.
It's like,
this dude's life is so fucking dramatic.
Even Oprah won't touch it,
you know,
it's like so,
so,
so full of highs and lows and all that stuff.
But his,
his,
his stuff.
When I look back on my earlier stuff,
I'm like,
you know,
I was always trying to be dark and like evil and like,
go to the,
go to the evil place or right.
Really clean.
But I'm like,
what I really should have been doing,
it's like watch Schimmel,
just watch,
right.
A great joke and just like let the natural organic of the,
of the sadness inside of me like,
you know,
come out,
you know?
But uh,
shit Shammo like is his stuff is classic.
I think his stuff is more evergreen than a lot of people's,
cause it's really,
you know,
about topics that are,
evergreen,
whatever relationships and,
you know,
health and all that kind of stuff.
So I'm a big fan of his.
Yeah,
he was great.
He,
you know,
he had some brilliant jokes
and I love a fucking,
the fact that like,
you know,
uh,
he did that special and then at the end he showed us the pictures,
you know,
did you see his last question?
It's a fucking,
it's sweet.
Special.
Yeah.
You know,
cause he had just beat,
you know,
cancer and you know,
it's just like no one ever would have thought that he would end it the way he
did.
It's sad ending.
Well,
a car accident,
you know,
I mean,
what do you do any special?
He finally,
you know,
Ba and shows pictures of his kids,
like the,
he supposedly wasn't able to have children because of other treatments.
The Chemo therapy and of course,
you know,
he Shem also,
he has two beautiful twins and I was like a real sweet thing.
I thought,
you know,
it's weird for comedy like after an hour of Dick Jokes and see pictures of
children.
But yeah,
I miss that dude.
I,
I used to see him around.
I wish I knew,
lived in my neighborhood.
I lived in this area.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I used to run into,
I ran into him a couple times.
It's great guy.
It's fucking,
yeah,
that,
that's a sad thing.
But I,
I I,
oh,
tons to those,
those kinds of things.
We all do my guys,
right?
We all do.
We,
I mean we,
we owe to each other.
I think,
you know,
it's,
it's uh,
one of the things,
the reasons why,
you know,
you were talking about the,
the wave of Boston comics that came up,
you know,
the Depaulo is,
and all those guys,
they all know each other.
You know,
the reason why everybody was so good is because so many people were so good.
You just had to do well.
What's the predictive power was the first guy that I saw that was kind of my age
who was a killer,
had water and I was like,
wow.
Yeah.
And he fucking,
his crowd work took,
made everyone else's crowd work,
look like you were doing bingo.
Like you go right for the throat.
And to this day I always have memories of just him taking on bachelor parties
and like just fucking drama.
A great and just like,
you know,
you're like,
it was like watching an epic battle like Godzilla vs Mothra kind of a great
joke.
Right?
He has a great joke writer and he's also a great political,
you know,
even though he's really hardcore right wing,
his stuff is dead on.
So
no,
he doesn't have anything that he says it isn't backup with thought.
I saw nick like early on and nick like actually,
uh,
gave me a lot of hope cause I used to go on stage and I'd be like,
man,
I look like I'm meathead does.
I never saw you guys when you were young comics,
you were already polished guys.
Oh really?
When did you,
uh,
when did we meet?
We met in the night.
Yeah,
but you already were headlining and you were like,
you know,
like you said you're doing all these gigs and I'm sure you were like already had
at least a half hour special lawyers.
We're on deck for one.
Yeah.
Well,
I think I did a an MTV half hour comedy on our first.
Maybe I did that maybe right before you and I met or something like that.
It was in that,
in that neighborhood.
I still suck.
Then I was just,
I was,
I feel like I'm going to suck this weekend.
I'm just telling you,
but it's good to see you watch you suck.
Where Phoenix,
it'd be a new type of suck.
That's the only thing.
Fresh paint on the old suck.
Um,
I forgot what my point was about sucking in the beginning.
I love that.
I love that you say that.
You know,
cause I always feel like I,
it's like,
am I ever going to get good at this?
People say differently.
You know,
I heard this one guy say that he's never bombed and he said,
yeah,
that's creepy.
It's,
that drives me nuts.
Really.
What do you mean?
How has he that even impossible?
What have you learned?
Nothing.
That's like a person walking through life saying,
I've never made a mistake.
You want something to drink or we'd done I think wrap this up.
I gotta I know I've got a role,
but uh,
I better sounds a cigarette outside.
It's five 20.
We've had a long show.
Hey Joe,
amazing show
Joe for going way too long and honestly,
uh,
not seeing you.
And I want to see you live.
And I'm like,
I said,
uh,
you guys have a sweet thing.
Thanks for helping me get the word out about the show.
Let's do a Gig together somewhere.
I would just do a theater degree.
Honestly.
I would love it.
Let's do it.
I hope your people would want me on the shelf because I know they're like
fanatical.
You know,
this is a little bit because I sucked down and I suck.
Now we should all come up with our first bit.
I'll do my first wreck right now.
The crying Indian Joe.
Which one is it?
Which was like the crying Indian.
You remember like what the pollution,
how old,
you know,
you could actually say the word Indian,
native American.
It's like the crying and it was like,
you know,
people,
it's not the pollution.
He has an allergy and I've seen that joke redone like a million different ways
on in cartoons and all that stuff.
But that was like the first time I was like,
wow,
I really came up with something edgy here.
Wow.
Joke was about,
uh,
hot girls never get speeding tickets.
It was so bad that it was like,
this is what it's like.
I'm already jealous.
Do you realize how fast you were going?
No,
I don't.
Do you like my tits?
You know,
so I do.
Here's a warning.
That was my bed.
I actually wrote that.
Everyone thought I'm like,
fuck I exactly what?
This is a good one.
That's a notebook with a big star next to it.
That's what I
circled.
That put a star next to that bitch.
I'm close with that motherfucker.
Week tools to work with.
You know,
you ever go back and like look at some of your old books.
Love it.
No,
no.
I used to have this joke about Bette Midler's gynecologist and it was like,
it was like,
Oh,
a fucking long joke about him pulling things out of her vagina.
No,
I love that.
I love tax.
I love it.
And you,
but Jimmy Hoffa,
Jimmy Hoffa was in her vagina and I thought he was buried in giants stadium.
Holy Shit.
That is giant stadium and here comes the giants
and so bad it just such a terrible,
I didn't think any of those thoughts other than this might work.
You know,
these aren't like things that really resonated with me.
It was just,
I was just trying to put together some tool that I could use on stage and get a
laugh.
Well that's,
I love that you like look back on the joke and you're like,
oh I know.
But you know somewhere if someone's doing a version of that joke right now to
drive you crazy when you put out like a CD or something and then you have the
joke for another month and you'd come home with a new fucking tax.
I hate it.
I,
I tried send,
it will be fixed by a software update.
You know,
where you can update your,
your CV.
It was really easy to record like CD quality stuff.
It wouldn't be,
but you know when you record a CD,
it's a pain in the ass.
You have to have an audio engineer and you have to make the crowd and you know,
that's another thing,
man,
I'm glad you said it where you always come up with like you figured out the
puzzle,
but the game's over and you're like,
oh my God,
I just came up with the best part of it and then that new tagline leads into a
way better bit.
You're like,
oh,
what do I do?
Because now I have the first part on this CD and everybody's heard it.
But the second part is like,
it doesn't stand alone,
but with that other part it becomes amazing.
You just have to rewrite something similarity and it's really hard to do.
Ari has a couple like that where he's really,
like I said,
I asked him about a tagline.
I said,
you said it like this before.
He goes,
actually I stole my joke from another joke that I had stole it from myself.
He like stole parts of it.
I'll go,
oh,
see you.
I see you.
You redid your own joke.
Oh yeah,
you did.
You swapped it around the gods of comedy work like that,
which is,
I'm glad you brought that up because that is like one of those things where you
never know.
But then like how about the joke that you've never told before,
but you say it on the CD and it works.
So that's how the God balances out.
Like you know this.
Isn't that the most fun moment ever?
When you're onstage and you say,
I say I did something in Manchester.
I don't know what it is.
I have to go back and listen to the recording,
but I went on this totally new tangent and it was crushing and I was listening
to,
I even said when I was on stage,
somebody right downtown.
Yeah,
I say that.
I don't know what the fuck.
Yeah,
I love that too.
Yeah.
I like this fucking thing.
And then,
then,
then you'll hear it and you're like,
oh,
I can make it better.
And then you'll keep twisting into until it sucks and you're like,
what the fuck I've created and now I have destroyed.
Worst is when you're tired or saying something and then you'd go into it and you
wish you didn't like as you started it,
as you started the bit,
you're like,
oh,
have I done,
I don't like this bit anymore.
And I'm talking to him coming down.
I'm faking my enthusiasm and uh,
oh,
that's the word.
It's like when you got it,
it's a high energy bit.
Oh,
it's the worst.
And you're faking it and you just feel like such an idiot as you're about to go
into the big part.
And we really going to do the big part here.
Let's do the big part.
And you're like,
oh,
it's funny.
Like a phone call on your pocket and the audience,
now the audience knows the audience knows the smell it,
those animals.
You're right.
Those fucking savages.
Go see Dave Attell this weekend.
People of Phoenix.
Sorry for clapping about,
that's the weed and the coffee talking then and watch Dave's old porn
thursday@eleventhirtyeleventhirtyonshowtimedarn.com.
Can I be on one?
I'd love for you to do it.
I'm hoping.
I'm hoping there's another season because there's so many great comics who could
do it and this porn people like are into it.
So it's like,
you know,
we're just scratching the surface here now.
So it's,
it's great.
And uh,
for those of you,
like I said,
who support not only Joe and also,
uh,
you know,
just live comedy.
Thank you so much for,
uh,
coming out and helping us.
We love better.
So thank you.
Yeah.
If it wasn't for the audience members mean this is the only odd,
it's the only art form really.
You have to,
we have an audience in front of a crowd.
it's an interactive art form.
There is no other way I have to write,
I have to have to sit alone and come up with ideas and stuff,
but there's no doubt about it that we need the crowd so we can only be as good
as the crowd.
And you have a great crowd.
I'm still a huge fan of standup comedy.
I know that you are to it.
Yeah.
It's fun fucking art form to watch,
man.
And we're very fortunate that we have with friends like Norton and Bill Burr and
Nick Depaula and all these I love,
I love watching the new guy,
like to just build the,
build a bit up there or like find something.
I think it's,
you know Brendan Walsh,
you know what?
I don't know.
I don't know these guys as well as I should,
but I've seen like snippets,
I like just anybody who's like trying to fight the good fight.
He's exactly fighting the good fight.
That's cool.
And there's a lot of those guys,
they're coming up now and you know,
because of podcast,
because of stuff like this,
they have a venue.
They have,
I mean we,
we let people know about Sam triple.
You will let people know about Ari Shaffir it.
Yeah.
It's,
so this is a beautiful thing to be able to do this.
Never,
you know,
when we were younger we had to,
come up with a set and do it somewhere in seven minutes and keep it clean.
And really this is the real deal and I,
thanks for having me please.
It's been an honor.
It's been an honor and we'll figure out a way to do a gig together for sure.
That's it.
That one does.
Even a guest spot.
I just want to please,
let's do a big one together,
man.
Fuck.
You.
See some crazy place like Chicago or something,
but something like a haunted prison or something that's like when the pot
[inaudible] house.
It's play on the stage where Johnny Cash recorded full shitty button down.
There's so many options out there.
Yes.
Thank you to everybody.
Thank you to all the people.
Please follow Dave on Twitter.
It's a t,
t e l l,
or we'll go to old porn with adult porn,
which is like adult porn with a zero.
That's all right.
Oh,
the porn has a zero.
Can't say
porn on a Twitter.
Oh,
you can?
Yeah.
Well there's a girl who called herself evil cunt.
Oh Wow.
That was her Twitter name.
She was the girl that,
uh,
that busted out,
um,
who was married to Sandra Bullock.
Jimmy J.
Jesse James [inaudible].
Jesse James.
Yeah.
That girl who she,
she,
she like ratted him out and sold the story.
About Hillary's banging her and sent all his dirty text messages that she sent
him.
And uh,
she was evil con on Twitter.
That's who she was.
Yeah,
that was,
we doesn't chiclets embracing the role,
man.
That would look great on a tee shirt.
He's a freak.
You're like those tattooed girls.
Those girls tatted up to the gills.
Foreheads says pray for us sinners and big script on her forehead.
Yet on wheel.
Yeah.
That's how I'm,
we'll sign.
Have you ever had a fully tatted up suicide girl?
I just liked your style.
I like,
I'm fucking,
yeah,
I like,
I'm like that crazy David.
Tell Ladies and gentlemen,
go see him this weekend in Phoenix,
Arizona at what does it again,
stand up live standup live in Phoenix,
Arizona.
I'm sure the information is available online.
Um,
Duncan Trussell and I,
this Friday night we'll be at the comedy and Magic Club in her most a beach.
Oh,
that's a sweet ride.
Birch.
And the next set a Friday in San Jose.
We're doing two shows at the Improv with Joey Diaz and Sam motherfucking triply.
So this Friday is a comedy magic club in Hermosa Beach.
Next Friday,
San Jose,
California.
Thank you to [inaudible] and Thursday.
Oh,
that's right.
This Thursday.
You fucking freaks.
We're doing a freak show.
Who's on it,
Jody?
So far we got Joey Diaz,
I,
Felicia,
Michael's,
you.
And uh,
there's some other Duncan might be able to do it so we might be able to Zam
bitches.
And that's this Thursday night at eight o'clock.
Correct?
That's at 10 o'clock,
nine o'clock,
9:00 AM nine o'clock at the Ice House in Pasadena.
Ice House,
comedy.com Ice House in Pasadena is the shit.
It's a cool fucking room.
It's an 85 seat room that we're doing.
This is a little tiny intimate room and it will sell out as soon as we put it on
Twitter.
So chomp on that shit,
bitches.
Got To icehouse comedy.com um,
that's it.
Thank you to the fleshlight.
Go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link for the fleshlight entering the cone Dame Rogan,
and you will get 15% off the number one sex toy for men.
And,
uh,
thank you to [inaudible] Dot com o n n I t,
makers of Alpha brain,
the cool shit for your dome pills that we sell,
entering the code name Brogan,
and you get 10% off that.
Uh,
we will see you on Thursday.
This Thursday.
We'll be back again with Dunkin motherfucking Trussell hall lunch boy.
And,
uh,
that's it.
Thank you everybody.
Thank you David Towel.
Thank you,
Jesus.
Okay.